[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
מה לעשות? לא נעים.
מה? היה קורה אם?
יש. רגע זה?
לא טוב? שלום לכולם.
אנחנו נמשיך לדבר היום על פרי טריינינג ואחרי זה נעבור לדבר על פוסטרים שלו.
שהם די מוזר, אבל זה השם שהתקבע. כן, בגדול.
טוב, נראה אם אולי יישאר לנו קצת זנב של ההרצאה של הפוסט טריינינג לשבוע הבא, אבל בגדול אלה פרקי החובה שתכננתי.
אני רוצה לדבר בשבוע הבא קצת על יישומים של בינה מלאכותית.
ולדבר על תוכניותיה. ובאופן כללי איך מגיעים ממצב של טקסט שאתם פשוט מוצאים איפשהו מתוקנים למשהו שנראה ככה כמו אינפוט Elm?
בשיעור האחרון אני חושב שאני אעשה שיעור חזרה.
זה מה שאני בדרך כלל עושה, אם יש עניין בזה.
זאת אומרת, אני יודע שיש פער די גדול על המבחן. נכון, זה סוף יולי המבחן.
יש כאן עניין בשיעור חזרה. יש שאלות מהקהל?
אוקיי, אז בואו נעשה ככה, תשלחו לי פשוט שאלות. בשבועיים הקרובים.
מבחנים מוכנים? כן כן, נעלה את המבחנים ואתם יכולים גם לעיין שם או שאלות על חומר שעלו ונחזור על זה.
אוקיי, בסדר, אז דיברנו על על פרי טריינינג ועל קונטקסט של is wedding Weddings.
דיברנו על זה שבעצם הרעיון הבסיסי של Pre Training נכון הוא בעצם הרעיון הבא.
אנחנו אומרים תראו, יש לנו דאטה מוגבל יחסית עבור משימה נתונה.
נכון, כי אנחנו צריכים תיוג אנושי. זה משהו יקר ודורש הרבה מאמץ.
מטבע הדברים יהיה לנו כמות מוגבלת של דאטה, אבל עושר התופעות בשפה, אפילו המילים השונות יש די הרבה, שלא לדבר על ביטויים ומבנים שונים.
וכן, כל העושר הגדול שיש בשפה כנראה לא יתבטא באותו אוסף באותו לייבל דאטה עבור Task ספציפי.
אנחנו צריכים להשתמש במשאב שהוא משאב נפוץ.
וספציפית באיזה משאב נפוץ נשתמש? טקסט?
כן, טקסט. כן, בדיוק מה שנקרא טקסט בדרך כלל.
פשוט טקסט שקיבלנו בצורתו הגולמית. כן, בלי איזה שהוא תיוג או משהו כזה.
כן, בדרך כלל אחרי שעבר איזשהו פרי Processing שנדבר עליו קצת בשיעור הבא, שזה יכול להיות לעיתים חשוב,
אבל בגדול פשוט טקסט שזמין לנו בכמויות אדירות, בדרך כלל מהרשת, ומה שאנחנו נעשה זה בעצם נשתמש, אבל הדאטה הזה לא מתויג.
אז מה אפשר לעשות עליו? אפשר להמציא עליו משימה? כן, מין או גזילה או ריצה כזאת שמה חשוב לנו שם.
אובזילר יהיה תז כזאת. תהיה שאותה אנחנו מנסים לפתור בפרי טריינינג.
לרוב אנחנו מנסים לאמן את המודל לאן אנחנו מנסים לאמן את המודל בפרי טריינינג.
אם נוסיף שורה על המבנה של השפה. כן, בדיוק.
אז צריך שכדי לפתור את המשימה הזאת נדמה שעל הדרך צריך לפתור כל מיני משימות שכן יכולות להיות חשובות לנו בכל מיני בעיות.
NLP, נכון. והדבר השני כמעט ברור מאליו ולהגיד אותו אנחנו רוצים שזה תהיה משימה שאפשר לעשות בלי תיוג אנושי, נכון?
בסדר, אז אנחנו רוצים משימות קשות או קשות באופן שקשור לכל מיני מבנים בשפה וכל מיני פרדוקס שאנחנו רוצים לעשות לגבי השפה,
אבל ניתן לבצע את זה באמצעות לייבל טקסט. זו הייתה בעיה פתוחה במשך הרבה שנים.
ואז באזור 2017 מודל בשם אלמו, וזמן קצר אחריו מודל בשם ברט שמיד.
אני אחזור. על מה הכוונה שם בעצם? נתנו לנו איזושהי דרך לאמן מודל באופן הזה ובעצם להשתמש בו כפרמטר Evaluation בשביל fine tuning.
אוקיי, כלומר, אנחנו עכשיו חושבים על הסופר וויס Task כמשהו שמתחיל ממודל שקודם עבר Pre training.
קודם עבר אימון מאד רציני על איזשהו Clear task, והדבר הזה בעצם מגדיר את אתחול הפרמטרים.
מכיוון שהבעיה היא כזאת שהיא רגישה לתנאי ההתחלה, כן רגישה לתנאי האתחול של הפרמטרים בצורה ניכרת.
אנחנו בשאיפה נרוויח איכשהו מזה. אז לפעמים קוראים לדבר הזה גם representation learning.
לא יודע אם יצא לכם לשמוע את המושג הזה באיזשהו הקשר למידת ייצוג.
כן, באיזה הקשר? נגיד שם באימייל?
משתמשים בזה? כן, נכון. אז לפעמים קוראים לזה representation learning.
מושג קצת עמום, אבל בגדול הכוונה שלו היא בערך זו.
כן. הכוונה היא שהפריט Rand מודל כן, במהלך הפרה Training נדע לייצר ייצוגים טובים שבעצם יתבטאו בפורמט.
הפרמטרים של המודל בעצם יחולו ככה.
בעקבות הפרי טריינינג.
גילו ככה שבעצם הייצוג שהוא יפלוט עבור טקסט נתון כן ה output של הרשת עבור איזשהו טקסט נתון שאנחנו משתמשים בה כדי לבצע את הפריט טריינינג,
בעצם ישקף איזשהו ייצוג שהוא ייצוג מוצלח של השפה.
אנחנו בונים על ייצוג מוצלח ואז כל מה שיישאר לסופר Voice Learning זה פשוט לקחת את הייצוג הזה.
וכמו שבמקרה של מודלים נכון של CRM והיה Linear Model שהיה לנו פונקציית פיצ'רים מוגדרת ידנית, אז עכשיו לא יהיה לנו בדיוק את זה.
יהיה לנו פונקציית פיצ'רים שמוגדרת על ידי מודל מורכב, מודל של נירלט, אבל הרעיון יהיה דומה.
עוד הבדל חוץ מזה שכאן הוא נלמד וב feature function של ה craft נגיד הוא היה מוגדר ידנית.
עוד הבדל חשוב. בחזרה לשיעור הקודם.
מה דעתכם על ה feature function? כן בזמן האימון. האם הפיצ'ר Function בתחילת האימון יהיה אותו הדבר כמו שהיא בסוף האימון בcss CSS?
אותו דבר. נכון, זה סתם איזשהו מודול שכתב אותו. מה קורה כאן?
כן, לרוב ממשיכים לעדכן. אוקיי, יש גם גישות שלא עושות את זה.
יש גישות שעושות את זה בצורה מוגבלת. כן, חלקכם, אני יודע, שמעתם לקחתם קורסים יותר מתקדמים?
שמעתם על דברים כמו לא רע או כל מיני שיטות אחרות לעדכן שהן יותר ככה?
זהירות. אבל בגדול זה גם הבדל משמעותי.
כן, צריך לראות את הקונטקסט, אבל ברור שזה לא זה.
זה פחות מעניין נשים צעירות. הביצועים הם בדרך כלל אותם ביצועים. סליחה על התנועה.
איך הייתם עושים את זה? מבחינת ביצועים זה כבר הרבה יותר טוב, וגם יש בזה היגיון אינטואיטיבי.
כשאתה צריך לממן את בערך כוס קפה, אתה צריך המון המון פרמטרים שאתה צריך אותו בשביל למסמס את זה.
לא צריך את זה פעם. נו, אז? אז אם ככה אתה מסכים אז אם ככה אתה די מסכים.
לא, לא, אני מסכים. כאילו אני שואל אם יש סיבה לא לעסוק בה.
אבל גם כשאתה אוסף אתה לא יודע. אבל גם כשאתה עושה fine tuning אתה.
אנשים בדרך כלל לא עושים fine tuning עם איזשהו learning rate מאוד גדול שלגמרי משנה את הפרמטרים בצורה מאוד גדולה.
כן, תמיד זה יותר מניע אקספרסיבי. כן.
אוקיי, ודיברנו קצת על ברט. בוא נזכיר איך עובד האימון של ברט ברט.
זוכרים מה הרעיון? אולי לפני הפרטים?
אולי מישהי או מישהו יכולים להזכיר לנו? לא הפרטים, לא בדיוק הספציפי של טריינינג.
מה זה ברט? מה הוא עושה? מה עושים איתו?
כן, באמת. הוא מנסה לפתור את המשימה של מאסק וליל שם.
וגם זה הוא עושה עם הקוביות. אוקיי. אתם לא רואים אותו?
כן. אז מה? מה שנקרא מאסק Language model. נכון, מאסק Language model זה חיה מסוג קצת חדש מהסוג שהכרנו נכון לפני כן.
מה זה mask language model? כן, בדיוק.
נכון, זה הרעיון. זה כמו close test. במקום לחזות את המילה הבאה זה חוזה את המילים המנוסחות.
ובעצם הרעיון הוא שהמשימה הזאת היא משימת פרי טריינינג טובה גם היא.
יש לה אפילו יתרונות מסוימים על גבי הקן ה left right, פרי טריינינג.
כן, כי בעצם הוא לוקח בחשבון את שני הצדדים.
אז פוטנציאלית הוא יכול כן לקודד בעצם יותר בקלות את גם מילים שמופיעות אחרי הטקסט וגם אחרי המילה הנתונה שאנחנו רוצים לייצג, וגם כאלה שמופיעים לפניה.
אז יש לזה יתרונות בהקשרים מסוימים. בגדול, זו איזושהי משימת פרי טריינינג שעליה אחרי זה אפשר לבנות לעשות fine tuning.
לפי הפרדיגמה שראינו קודם כן, ודיברנו ספציפית על איך זה מאומן.
כן שמגדירים בוחרים 15 אחוז מהתקנים. חלק ממסכים חלק מחליפים באופן רנדומלי, חלק בשירים וכן הלאה.
אני לא אחזור פה על כל הפרטים, אבל מה שחשוב זה שבעצם.
כן, הפרי טריינינג. הפרי טריינינג בעצם נכון הוא מבוסס או הארכיטקטורה של ברט ומהלך פרי טריינינג.
זה איזשהו Transformer Encounter. נכון, Transformer Another סטנדרטי שהוא מוציא בעצם ה output שלו זה סדרת.
אנחנו בדרך כלל הולכים להם ברט עם Bodies או קונטקסט Listening Beings של המילים.
נכון, לכל מילה יש איזשהו וקטור שיוצא מ transformer Encounter.
אנחנו חושבים עליהם כייצוג של המילה זה.
אחרי זה עובר Linear פרודקשן ו soft max כדי לקבל התפלגות על פני אוצר המילים.
אוקיי, ועל זה ומושגי זה מוגדר הלוס. אחרי זה כשרוצים לעשות fine tuning מה עושים?
נגיד אני רוצה עכשיו להשתמש בזה כדי לחזות part of speech טקסט.
כן, עשיתי ניתוח לטווח ארוך. בדור האחרון אני מרגיש שכבר מספיק להבין אותו.
כן, אז מוסיפים, קוראים לזה לפעמים Classification head.
כן, זה קצת מבלבל לשם head, כי זה לא attention head זה משהו אחר.
Classification head. דבר הדמיון היחידי זה ששתיהן רשתות קטנות כאלה.
אז בגדול Classification Head זה מין רשת קטנה הרבה פעמים פשוט לעיני הרבה soft.
מקס אולי טיפונת יכולה להיות יותר מורכבת גם בדרך כלל לא תהיה מאוד מורכבת שבעצם מתחלים אותה.
איך מאבחנים אותה? לא תפס, אבל כן, זה איזשהו משהו רנדומלי.
אין לנו מידע על זה מאתרי Training. נכון, זה משהו חדש שנוסף, אז אנחנו זורקים את החלק הזה.
מוסיפים פה עוד משהו שמאובחן רנדומלית. איכשהו אין לנו עליו איזשהו ניחוש טוב ומאמנים את הרשת.
בעצם את כולם הם עושים לה בעצם Fine Tuning עם הסופר וייז דאטה.
אגב, למה Classification head? אמרתי שהוא לא מסובך מדי.
למה? למה אני מתייחס פה? למה שלא יהיה מסובך מדי? מה הוא עומק?
אז מה מפריע? מה מפריע לי לשים Classification Head? מסובך? אה כן, צריך.
למה אתה סומך על זה שהרשת מאחורה עשתה את העבודה?
ואם לא, לא כדאי לי לגבות את עצמי קצת, להוסיף לה איזה מעבד מקפיץ the Purpose?
כאילו אוקיי, אז מה אני מאבד בעצם?
מה זאת אומרת עוגן כבד? אני אקבל תשובה למה פה יש לי גז מיליון פרמטרים.
לא יודע מה 350 מיליון פרמטרים. אז אני מוסיף כאן עוד איזה כסף קטן אני מתקמצן על להוסיף עוד איזה שכבה או שתיים.
אולי כבר בסיפור שלך. אוקיי, נכון. אז מה ההבדל בעצם המהותי בין איך שאני מאמן את זה לאיך שאני מאמן את ה classification Head?
זו בעיה נכון? כי סופרוויז'ן צריך label data. נכון?
בדיוק. אוקיי. כמות הרבה יותר קטנה של data. יש פה הבדל מאוד משמעותי עקרוני.
קודם כל כמובן שזה לא פיזי גם בזמן שינה.
ספורט בזמן. זו משימה שהיא סופר יש פה.
האם אין חשש לאובר דייטינג? כן. למה?
בגדול, כי אובר זו בעיה של Data Science City.
עכשיו האם לא יכול להיות over fighting? כן. ודאי לא טענתי את זה.
וככל שמילים או טקסטים מסוימים הם יותר נפוצים, אז גם האיכות של פרזנטציה שלהם עולה.
זאת אומרת, אם אתם, אם למשל אתם תלכו ונגיד תסתכלו על speech tracking.
כן. עכשיו ברור. או כמעט בוא נאמר סופר אינטואיטיבי.
כמעט מובן מאליו שמספר הפעמים שנגיד המילה ביל מופיעה בקמפיין טיעונים כאלו עם Part of Speech שלה ישפר באופן ממוצע לפחות את הביצועים שלי על המילה הזאת.
אבל הדבר המעניין הוא שגם מאוד משפיע, מסתבר.
מספר הפעמים שביל הופיע בקטגוריית רימינג.
אוקיי, אז זה גם משנה, בוודאי אם אנחנו מדברים על צירופי Bay גרם זאת ריי גראם, אז כן, שהולכים ונהיים יותר Sparks.
אז כן, יכולה להיות גם בעיה של ספר Set. יכולה להיות בעיה של ספר סאטיבה ופרי טריינינג פשוט היא בעיה שבדרך כלל קורית.
בשלב יותר מאוחר כי יש לך פשוט הרבה יותר סטטיסטיקה, אז אתה יכול.
כן, יש הרבה את זה אנחנו לא מלמדים בקורס הזה, אבל נכון, יש את השאלה כמה data בעצם על כמה data לאמן Transformer עם Cover, נגיד לברט.
כן, מה השלב שבו כבר יש תפוקה שולית, פוחתת וכמעט אפסית?
אולי אובר פיסטינג? איך אני עושה ריגול? אריזה? כי אנחנו לא כל כך נכנסים לדברים האלה, אבל אתה צודק באופן עקרוני גם גם לשם נקי.
בסדר. ובעצם סיימנו את השיעור הקודם בזה שדיברנו על זה ש BRT בעצם משיג תוצאות.
בעצם, הברדלס שיפר את הדיוק של מגוון אדיר של משימות.
הפרדיגמה הזאת התבררה להיות פרדיגמה מאוד אפקטיבית.
הגדלים שבארץ עבד עליהם. זה גדלים שהיום נראים לנו כאילו קטנטנים.
כן, זה היה מאות מיליוני פרמטרים.
זה סדר גודל של ברט, אבל זה כבר נתן שיפור מאוד משמעותי על בסיס בעצם מהקונטקסט של list עם Branding Annual Connector עם Bands.
כן. כמו כן היה לנו דוגמה לזה בקורס.
זוכרים את השם? לא מודל עם Padding שמייצר לנו מה זה נון קונטקסט עם Padding באמצע?
מה כן? אותו וק בדיוק למדנו על Skip גרם מודל שהוא חלק מהחבילה.
קוורטרבק מה זה non context police? מה הכוונה של הטקסטים שהם לא טקסט?
ברור שזה כן לא נכון. אז לא משנה בעצם גם אם הוא מאוד מפורט.
כן, זה תלוי רק בוורד פור נכון באיך הוא כתוב. כאילו בסדר, אז הקונטקסט עם Padding, ובפרט הפופולרי שביניהם.
אבל גם אחרי זה היו עוד הרבה שכלולים ושיפורים והרחבות עשה בעצם הבדל מאוד גדול במגוון גדול של משימות.
דיברנו על כמה בודדות, אבל בגדול פחות או יותר השתמשו בזה בכל מקום.
כן, כל מקום סביר מבחינת הקן מבחינת הביצועים להריץ משהו עם כמה מאות מיליוני פרמטרים כנראה השתמשו
ב bird שם במקום הפיצ'ר Functions מבוססי Non contact us או manual Defined או שילוב שלהם.
וזה באמת היה שינוי מאוד גדול בתחום. עכשיו אנחנו בעצם נעבור אם תרצו לשלב הבא.
כן, שזה כל הנושא של זירו שוט שופ Addiction שזה בעצם היה הגלגול הבא בתחום ה language Modeling.
כן, אז אם Birth אנחנו מדברים על סוף 2017 כן 2018 זה 2019 כל השנים שנות התהילה של של פרץ.
אז בעצם בשנת 2010 יצר מודל מאוד חשוב שנקרא GPT 3 של חברת Open AI, שבעצם הרעיון שלהם היה תעזבו אתכם מ fine tuning.
כן fine tuning זה בעיה. כי למה זאת בעיה?
כי אוקיי, fine tuning זה בעצם סוג של סמי סופר voice learning.
נכון, יש לנו פאזה שהיא מה שנקרא self סופר ווייס. כן, היא עם הלייבל data אז יש לנו סופר ווייס learning.
אז למרות שהפרי טריינינג מאוד מוריד את כמות הדוגמאות שאנחנו צריכים, אנחנו עדיין צריכים כמות יפה של דוגמאות.
כמה מאות, כמה אלפים. כן, זה תלוי במשימה. כן, לפעמים יותר מזה של דוגמאות מתויגות כדי להתחיל לראות איזשהו אפקט.
כן, כדי לקבל משהו סביר זה מסובך מדי לטעמם של ה open AI והם אמרו תעזבו,
אנחנו בעצם מציעים לכם את הדבר הבא תעשו זירו שוט או לחילופין Fusion שזה בעצם דברים מאוד דומים.
כן, למרות שיש איזשהו הבדל קונספטואלי, אבל הרעיון הוא בעצם הרעיון הוא שאנחנו רוצים לעשות.
הם קראו לזה In context learning in context learning.
זה מושג די מבלבל כי אין בו בכלל למידה במובן של שינוי של פרמטרים.
אבל ככה הם קראו לזה in context learning. והרעיון הוא בעצם שאתם לא צריכים יותר training מעבר לפרי training.
אוקיי, עשיתם tree training. עכשיו יש לכם איזשהו מודל? נגיד למשל מודל mask language מודל.
סתם לשם הדוגמה זה גם יכול להיות כזה left right language model.
ועכשיו אתם. מה שאתם רוצים זה לענות על איזושהי שאלה, כמו למשל What movies Did, בראד פיט Appear in?
או משהו כזה? אוקיי, אז מה אתם תעשו? אתם תקחו נגיד אולי כן?
אולי אתם תיקחו נגיד איזשהו משפט כמו Put a part in the movie ואז תמשכו כן ותנסו לראות מה חסר.
או אולי תוסיפו, קשרו את המשפט הזה לאיזשהו משפט.
נגיד ערך הוויקיפדיה של בראד פיט. כלומר קודם תמצאו מידע רלוונטי כן מרחבי הרשת או מוויקיפדיה או משהו ואז תחברו אליו.
כן, תעשו קונקרטי. ונציה שלו לפי Appeared in the movie ואז פשוט כן לא צריך.
לא צריך fine tuning. לא צריך להחליף את ה classification head.
נכון יש לנו בדיוק אותו Classification head. עכשיו זה לא בדיוק קלאסי.
פייר מהסוג שהכרנו הוא לא פשוט איזשהו אוסף נכון Labels שביניהם אנחנו מנסים להכריע, כמו בדרך כלל בסופר ווייס Learning.
עכשיו הלייבלים שלנו מהם הם פשוט מילים בדיוק.
פשוט המילים של אוצר המילים. כן אוקיי, אז המילים של אוצר מילים.
אז יש לי put in the movie ואז אני יכול לחזות מה זה.
כפי שאתם רואים כבר מהדוגמה הזאת אני נתקל ואני אתקל פה בקצת בבעיות טכניות שהרבה מהשמות של הסרטים הם לא Token אחד,
ואז אני צריך לדעת נכון, אולי נעשה פעם אחת mask פעם אחת שני mask, פעם אחת שלוש mask ואז צריך להחליט אם בסדר.
אז יש שם אולי קצת רודג'רס טכני, אבל בגדול זה הרעיון.
שנייה אחת אני רק זה five shot. שנייה מה עשיתי?
אוקיי, כן, איכשהו קפצתי על כן וסידרתי אותם.
נכון Future זה רעיון דומה לסרט hero shot.
מה ששם עושים בעצם זה מה שהם עושים.
זה מנוסים, סוג של סופר ווייס Learning.
בקטנה. בגלל זה הם קוראים לזה פישוט כאילו יש לכם מעט דוגמאות אימון.
אוקיי, כמה? בודדות בדרך כלל כן, אחת, שתיים, שלוש עשר.
כן, זה נחשב יחסית הרבה. אתם מכניסים אותם לקונטקסט?
כן, בעצם. במילים אחרות אתם פשוט בונים דוגמה.
כן, דוגמה ל influence שבה אתם מכניסים את הדוגמאות האלה.
כלומר, אתם לא משנים את הפרמטרים של המודל, אלא אתם אומרים למודל השפה הנה הטריפל איקס שלך.
אוקיי? What is a small fairy animals native to an example of sentence uses.
בלה בלה בלה בלה. To do means to keep up and down an example of a sentence a.
יאללה הוא type of visible. סוף דוגמה ראשונה. אוקיי.
Boring is a car with fast accelerator. טה טה טה טה טה?
Example of a sentence. אוקיי, הגיג מור גיגה מור.
Type of his musical instrument an example of contents that.
אתר. ואז מה שאתם יכולים לעשות בדוגמה שאתם באמת רוצים לפתור זה להתחיל את זה באותה צורה.
כן להגיד לא יודע. המילה הזאת והזאת אומרת ככה בקוריאנית.
An example of a sentence that uses the words whatever כן is time.
עכשיו תשלימו. כן. ואז למה הם קראו לזה few short learning?
כן אני כותבת learning במובן שדיברנו עליו אבל.
אבל כאילו בגלל שבעצם יש דוגמאות בתוך הקונטקסט אז אנחנו חושבים על זה גם כאיזשהו סוג של סופר ווייס Learning שלא משנה את הפרמטרים של המודל,
אלא באיזשהו מובן הפרי פיקס הופך להיות חלק מהפרמטרים.
אם תרצו רק שאלה פרמטרים מנוסחים בשפה טבעית. אוקיי, עכשיו היו שאלות.
כן. מלא. אוקיי.
רגע, אז אולי פריוריטי זה הציע? כן כן, ברור. אז זהו, נגיד שאתה אומר כאילו נגיד מבין לא עושים, לא עושים את זה, פשוט מביאים דברים בקונטקסט.
זה ייתן כאילו מצמצמים את הבעיה. אינדיקציה לקונטקסט עם מקורות רלוונטיים?
כן. אז בעצם זו השאלה איך מביאים את המקורות? זה אולי לא.
אז לא הזכרתי, רק נתתי דוגמה בשקף.
בגדול, במקור אין שום מקורות. מה שהוא עשה בפרי טריינינג זה זה.
את השילוב של היום אני לא לגמרי הבנתי. אוקיי, יש לך פרונט, נגיד שאלה כלשהי?
לא, אין לי פרונט. יש לי דוגמאות לאתר. אנחנו עכשיו במשימת לתת דוגמאות למילים שאנחנו מגדירים במשפט קצר.
אוקיי, זאת המשימה שלנו כאן. זאת פשוט דוגמה מהמאמר של האופן AI.
אוקיי. בסדר, אז זאת המשימה.
איך ייראה זירו שוט עבור המשימה הזאת? זה ייראה ככה?
What is a small fairy animal native to טנזניה. An example of the simpsons that is the world.
What הוא is? זה Generate?
זה זירו שופ? כאילו לא נתתי לו אף דוגמה למשפט כזה.
פשוט אמרתי לו הנה הפרי פיקס תשלים Fu שוט אומר לא, אני אגיד לך.
Your travelling an African method is very cut out pools.
ואחרי זה אולי אני אתן עוד כמה כאלה? To do for doodle means to צ'אמפה טה טה טה נגיד?
כמה דוגמאות לתשובות נכון? כן, גם השאלה וגם התשובה.
אתה רואה זה זה מסודרים. שאלת כאילו Instruction. כן זה דוגמה אה פתרון דוגמה.
פתרון דוגמה. פתרון זה האחרון הוא רק דוגמה בלי פתרון ותגן רת או לחילופין אתה יכול לא לתת.
אם אתה לא נותן את ההתחלה אז מה הוא יעשה אם תיתן לו נגיד את הפרי פיקס עד הקו הזה הוא יתן גם את החוסם.
כן, בדיוק אז הוא ימציא את זה לפחות את השאיפה. כן, הוא ימציא מילה חדשה.
נכון? הוא יגיד שהמילה לא יודע מה גולגול, היא אומרת בסמוי ווטאבר, כן, ציפור עם נוצות כחולות.
An example of sentence use the word. זה היא לא יודע מה כן אז פשוט מדהים.
ראיתי אנשים שאלו שאלות אם הפרויקטים הם Examples response, example response,
examples response ואז אתה מתפלל שהוא יבין שהוא צריך להמשיך באותו אופן ובזירה הוא שעות.
אתה אפילו צריך להתפלל יותר חזק, כי שם אתה אפילו לא בדיוק אומר לו מה אתה רוצה.
אתה רק איכשהו מקווה שהוא הבין את התבנית ויודע שהוא צריך להכניס פה משפט.
כן כן, זה קצת טיפשי לראות איך זה עושה את זה.
הרי טריינינג זה חיים טובים. בשניהם יש לך רק פרי טריינינג.
אוקיי, אז למרות שזאת משימת הפרידה, זו עוד משימה.
לא לא, לא פרי טריינינג כמו שהיה לנו קודם. כאן זה יהיה.
Language מודל כזה left right next. כאילו next וורלד אדיקשן במקרה של שנתתי קודם, אבל גם אפשר לעשות בזירה, או שעוד.
אפשר גם לעשות בזירה או פשוט כן לחבר אותם בינהם.
אז נגיד אתה יכול להגיד אוקיי, אני עכשיו רוצה לענות על השאלה What movies Did בראד פיט April?
אז אולי אני אנסח את זה כי כנראה סיכוי טוב יותר שתקבל תשובה שאתה מחפש.
אם תנסח את זה מחדש כמשפט חיווי, אבל אתה יכול לנסות פשוט לכתוב לו.
The answer to the cushion what movies did בראד פיט appear in the mask?
ואז תחזור את ה 100 או משהו כזה? כן? או אם זה left right פשוט לחזות את המילה הבאה.
כן, אולי זה מדע בטמן. כאילו בהתנצלות ויקיפדיה.
משפט מס על מה? על מה מתאמן הפרי טריינינג? כן, אבל אני אענה לך על זה.
נראה לי יותר בעיקר בשיעור הבא. אנחנו נדבר קצת על פרקטיקות, אבל אני אענה על זה בקצרה.
אבל בגדול תשים לב שזה בדיוק אותה שאלה גם רלוונטית לפה.
כן, אותה שאלה גם רלוונטית לפרטנר מתאמן נכון?
כי גם שם בעצם אתה מצפה ממנו לעשות.
אולי שם אתה מצפה ממנו גם לזהות ידע עובדתי, וכאן אולי תלוי במשימה שאתה רוצה לפתור,
אבל אם אתה עושה פיצ'ינג אז זה יותר ידע שפתי, אבל אין לו באמת הפרדה ביניהם.
אז כן, בדרך כלל מתאמנים באופן מאוד רציני על וויקיפדיה ומתאמנים על כל מיני דברים שעשו להם crossing מהרשת ולאף אחד אין כל כך מושג.
מעדיפים לא בדיוק לבדוק מה יש שם, כי זה יכניס אותך לכל מיני בעיות משפטיות.
מתאמנים על. כן כן, זה תלוי בהקשר.
נגיד בישראל יש פרויקט של בעצם יש המון קומפיוטר דאטה למדינה.
כן לממשלה, לכנסת. כאלה דברים. אז היו עבודות שעבדו עם זה?
כן, בעצם, כי פשוט יש שם כמות די גדולה של נתונים. וגם וויקיפדיה כמובן.
אז אתה יודע, זה בדרך כלל מה שיש. אתה מכניס אותו ומיקס כאילו הדאטה מיקס זאת כמה לקחת מוויקיפדיה?
כמה לקחת? אתה יודע כמה אפקטים עשית על ויקיפדיה? כמה זה סוד שמור שחברות לא מספרות.
כן, זו שיטה של כיף אפילו שלא יודעים שהיא נשמעת כאילו היא כזה טיפים לאיך לעשות אינפורמציה.
אבל לא תמיד פרמטר נכון לא משנים את הפרמטרים בכלל.
רוצים דוגמאות? תעשה ככה. לא. רגע, עוד לא דיברנו על הצ'אט ועוד לא דיברנו עוד על הצ'אט.
לא, לא, זה פשוט חשוב לי להפריד כי עוד לא דיברנו על צ'אט. הוא מוסיף עוד איזה שהוא קומפוננטה על גבי זה שנדבר עליה.
כרגע אנחנו מדברים על אוטו קומפלט. אם תרצה כן אוטו קומפלט מתוחכם, אז בוא נגיד לפעמים אנחנו לא משתמשים במודל רק מוזיקה.
נכון נכון נכון נכון?
נכון, זו שיטת כפי שזה מוגדר עכשיו, או כפי שהגדירו את זה במאמר Open ai שהציעו את שיטות הזירוז והפיוס, שוט שגם לפעמים נקרא ביחד context learning.
למרות השם המבלבל, זה באמת פילוסופי. קונספט אינטראקטיבי.
כן, זה לא שם כל כך מוצלח, אבל זה פשוט השם של תחום שנע מאוד מהר ומנוהל במידה רבה על בסיס אינטרסים עסקיים ולא מדעיים.
אז השמות לפעמים משקפים את זה? כן. למרות שיש שיטענו שזה כן learning ובעצם אנחנו לא הגדרנו learning כמו שצריך.
אז אתה יודע כמה זה טוב? אז?
כן. רגע. אוקיי, סליחה.
כן. אז זה בעצם היה הרעיון של שעל פיו shoot learning.
בגדול לעשות רק פרי טריינינג ולתת דוגמאות או בזירה הוא shoot.
אפילו לא לתת דוגמאות.
מה שרציתי לומר בהקשר הזה, זה שאמנם ברט הוא זה שהתחיל את ה או לא יודע אם התחיל, אבל בוא נאמר, היה מחלוצי המגמה של קונטקט World in Berlin.
אבל בעצם כיום הפרדיגמה של Mask Language Models היא פחות דומיננטית.
הסיבה לזה היא שמה ש bird בעיקר נותן זה ייצוג עבור.
זאת אומרת, היתרון שלו שהוא נותן ייצוג עבור כל מילה שמסתמך גם על הקדימה וגם על האחור.
כן, בעוד שאם יש לכם מה שמה שנקרא disorder only models כן, שזה מה שמדבר עכשיו.
זה כל פעם רק מסתכל אחורה ומנסה לחזות את המילה הבאה.
כלומר יש ייצוג פחות טוב למילים, אבל פחות ופחות אנשים ב NLP כנראה רוצים לייצג מילים יותר פשוט רוצים לבצע את המשימה.
אז בקיצור, ארכיטקטורה שהיום יותר דומיננטית זה ארכיטקטורת?
Only. כן, אם היה לנו את Bird שהוא היה אפשר לקרוא לו another only.
נכון, לא היה disorder. זרקנו אותו שם לו מין נורא פשוט שזה היה מין Linear.
נכון Linear large soft max כאן זה אומר.
זוכרים את ה Transformer? יופי, אתם כבר לא צריכים את ה Encounter.
למה אתם לא צריכים את ה Encounter? כי בעצם עכשיו אתם עובדים אתם כבר לא מתרגמים.
אפשר לדבר אולי בהמשך על איך אפשר להשתמש בזה. כן לתרגום.
אבל נגיד בבסיס אתם כבר לא מתרגמים. ולכן הרישא של הרישא של הטקסט היא בעצם מאותו עולם.
כן, היא לקוחה מאותו עולם כמו הדבר שאתם ההמשך שאתם רוצים לחזות.
אז כל מה שאתם צריכים זה את הדיכאון, כי הדיכאון לא מאפשר לכם להכניס Practice נכון טקסט עד נקודה מסויימת ולחזות את המילה הבאה.
אני לא בהכרח צריך את ה אקספרסיביות הנוספת שיש להן Loader שהוא מסוגל לייצג כל מילה על בסיס מה שלפני ומה שאחראי.
אני פשוט אציג את הקונטקסט. איזה igo כן? אז מספיק לי בשביל זה.
ואני כן אגיד אם אני רוצה להשלים את המילה הבאה. אני פשוט כן.
אתם מכירים את זה כבר?
מה רננים זה בעצם אני מכניס את הפרי פיקס בצד אחד מריץ את Transformer Recorder בדיוק כמו קודם, רק שעכשיו אין לו in order לעשות עליו cross attention.
אבל חוץ מזה הוא בדיוק אותו דבר ואני מייצר התפלגות על פני המילה הבאה.
כן והדיכאון בלוק הוא רק בעצם נהיה יותר פשוט.
נכון, כי כבר אין לי את הקרוס attention. כל מה שיש לי זה את המסך self attention ואת הפיד פורוורד.
בעצם כן. אוקיי, אז זה בסדר, אתם רוצים לחזור על זה עוד פעם?
ברור. אם אפשר עוד פעם עוד פעם?
כן. אה כן. אוקיי, אז Recorder only models and only models recorder only models.
זה בעצם מודלי שפה מבוססי Transformer? כן, עכשיו בתור מודלי שפה.
כן, להבדיל מודלי תרגום, אין משפט שהוא קלט שהוא מגיע מעולם אחד.
נגיד כתוב באותיות עבריות, נגיד פלט שהוא כתוב אולי באותיות אחרות סיניות או משהו.
אני רוצה לתרגם. כן belong with model יש לי פשוט רישא ואני כל פעם מנסה לחזות את המילה הבאה.
כן? אז בעצם במקרה כזה אני יכול להסתפק רק בדיכאון, אז בגלל זה קוראים לזה disorder only models, אבל אני עדיין יכול לעשות משהו מאוד דומה.
למה Transformer עושה רק שעכשיו ה encoding הוא Useless?
כן, אני יכול פשוט להוציא אותו החוצה.
אז איך נראה the code בלי Encounter? אולי בשביל זה?
אולי מה שחסר כאן זה זה. זה להיזכר שנייה איך נראה Transformer?
אולי זה אולי זה מה שהם. בואו ניזכר שנייה איך נראה Transformer דיכאוני?
כן. אז מה עשה Transformer די קודר? הוא בעצם קיבל את הפרי פיקס.
נכון, הוא קיבל את הפרי פיקס של התרגום.
נכון, בהתחלה בשכבה הראשונה הוסיף Position only Padding בסדר.
ואז בעצם כל בלוק שלו, כל בלוק של ה Transformer של טרנספורטר Disorder היה מורכב ממה שנקרא master attention או must מולטי hide attention.
אם יש לי יותר מראש אחד. נכון שאני כל פעם מעדכן, עושה Caching בעצם לאקטיביות שכבר עשיתי ורק מחשב את העמודה האחרונה.
כן כן, זה הנקודה שדיברנו ואז זה אומר ה output של זה נכנס ועושה.
Cross attention על הוקטורים שהגיעו Encounter ו הוקטורים שהגיעו מה mask extension של Deer.
אבל אם אין יותר Encounter כל החתיכה הזאת מיותרת.
נכון, כל החתיכה האמצעית זה בדיוק מה שרואים פה בשקף.
כן, כל בלוק סליחה, כל בלוק יש בו רק mask self attention.
יכול להיות multi headed כן, אז EMS multi attention ו forward.
בסדר, אני לא יכול לקחת את הצללית כאילו כל החתיכות, כל החתיכה, כל דבר עם גודל כזה יש לה איכות.
כן מה אני אגיד לכם, כל זה מיותר.
עכשיו הכל נכנס לפה. כן עד כן כל החתיכה הזאת.
אני לא יודע איזה צד אתה רואה את זה. אתה רואה את זה כשמאל? כן כן.
אוקיי. אין קונספט, אין קונספט.
אנשים כן, כבר אין מה לעשות חוץ אותנטיים. כן בדיוק. אחלה.
רגע. זה באמת בצורה מוזרה עכשיו אוקיי, אני שואל את עצמי איך לא היה לנו כאן קודם קודם?
כי ספק אין לנו אם יש לנו רק את ה.
כאילו יש רק את האם. בעצם באימון יש לנו input והאוטובוס.
וההספק אין. אז מה הכנסנו בהספק בדרך שלא העזנו קודם?
הכנסנו פשוט את הטקסט כמו שהוא, בלי מסכים.
כן לא. לא ראינו את הארכיטקטורה של בטא נכון?
שתי כניסות, אחד לניקוטין ואחד לאופניים.
נגיד במשימה של תרגום לא. רגע ברט.
שנייה, בוא נפריד. יש פה שלוש ארכיטקטורות. יש את הארכיטקטורה של ה transformer Encounter ואת רואה?
יש את ניסן. רגע, זה לא בכי? זה Transformer?
כן, זה נגיד לנשים translation או love דווקא machine translation.
אגב, לכל מקרה שבו אתה רוצה שעל input יהיה בעצם by direction Attention שזה לא יהיה mass attention.
כן שכל פעם רק נסתכל אחורה. אתם זוכרים את ההבדל הזה?
אוקיי, אם לא אז שווה לחזור שזה לא יהיה רק כנס Attention שמסתכל אחורה, אלא זה יהיה בית Direction.
Attention. כלומר כל attention יכול להסתכל על כל המילים שנכנסו לבלוק.
כן, זה המקרה של another decade. זה לא רק תרגום.
כן, זה גם יכול להיות באותה שפה. נגיד אני עושה Summary לפעמים גם משתמשים בין Code Recorder.
אתה אומר הנה אני אחזיר את כל הטקסט ל Encounter.
עכשיו הוא כל מילה יכול להבין אותה אולי בצורה הכי טובה, כי הוא לא רק רואה את מה שלפניה, הוא גם רואה שאחריה לא יודע מה.
מאיזושהי סיבה אתה חושב שזה רעיון יותר טוב. ועכשיו כל הטקסט הזה נכנס Encounter.
אתה מוציא output וקטורים עבור התקנים ועכשיו אתה מזין אותם לדיאלוג יותר ומייצר את התרגום מילה אחרי מילה.
גם אפשרי בהחלט. ארכיטקטורה שימושית זה encounter disorder. אוקיי, אולי אני אצייר אותם אחד ליד השני אז תראו את זה ואז נראה לי נצא להפסקה ותמשיך אחרי אז.
Recorder Recorder. Recorder Recorder נראה ככה.
אגב, זה לא חייב להיות Transformer. עקרונית כן. גם ב RNA זה ממש הגדרה אבסטרקטית.
כן, Encounter recorder יש לנו בעצם שני בלוקים.
שתי רשתות שלאחד מהם נכנס משהו שנקרא input.
ולשנייה נכנס ה output traffic.
ונכנס זה אולי לכמה ואולי לכמה מקומות. בגלל זה אני לא מצייר בדיוק.
אולי נכנס בכל שכבה משהו כזה, אבל הוא איכשהו מזין אותו.
צייר בצורה זו או אחרת ואז לזה אנחנו קוראים in order. וזה אנחנו קוראים סליחה ה Covers.
חוץ מזה יש לנו את ארכיטקטורת encounter only.
שבה יש איזשהו input טקסט. ומה שיוצא בסוף מהצד השני.
כן, זה קצת תלוי ב setting, אבל בדרך כלל עושים את זה כשרוצים ייצוג.
האמת שלאו דווקא למה להגביל? זה יוצא או וקטור אחד או סדרה של וקטורים שבאיזשהו מובן חושבים עליהם כעל ייצוג של האינפוט.
אוקיי, לפעמים אנחנו גם רוצים להרכיב עליו איזשהו Classification ולעשות פיקציה או שלא, ואנחנו רוצים את הווקטורים האלה.
לא יודע מה למשהו אחר לאיזושהי אנליזה כזאת או אחרת.
בסדר, אז יש פה את האינפוט ואז יש כל מיני וקטורים שיוצאים.
כן output vector. למשל Burton bad things ולפעמים כן או לא.
יש מעל זה Classification head שלוקח את output factors וחוזה משהו.
מה זה disorder only? זה מה שדיברנו עכשיו?
בעצם כאן יש את הפרי Fix.
כן שנכנסת ויוצא בדרך כלל כן, מה שיוצא פה זה איזשהו וקטור.
כן, איזשהו output vector שגם עליו עושים.
בונים בדרך כלל איזשהו Classification למשל של המילה הבאה.
כן או משהו כזה? בסדר, אז פה יש classification head.
זה מסמן את זה בצבע אחר. כי זה לא בדיוק חלק Encounter פה.
אוקיי. וספציפית ב Transformer. יש כאן קצת הבדלים.
נכון, כי הם בנויים טיפה אחרת.
נכון, הם שניהם self tension שמבוססים שהם מבוססי tension אבל בצורה אחרת.
האם קודר הוא מה שקראנו בידי regional Attention או self attention?
נכון והדי קודר הוא בעצם כל פעם עושה איטרציות בין מה שקראנו mask attention, נכון mask attention לבין cross attention שמסתכל גם על זה וגם על זה.
אוקיי, אז עושה masks attention cross attention כמו שראינו קודם.
במקרה של Encounter only in order עושה self attention.
נכון direction self fatigue disorder only.
מה הוא עושה? אז רק רק בעצם?
Speed tension? נכון, אולי הוא היה יכול לעשות גם קרוס אם היינו נותנים להם קוטר שמזין אותו.
אבל אם זה דיקור דורון רובין Encounter אז החלק הזה מתייתר.
בסדר, אז אלה שלושת ארכיטקטורות הבסיסיות. שלושת המופעים הבסיסיים שתמצאו.
לא רק Transformer. אבל בהקשר של הקורס שלנו בעיקר נדבר על Transformer.
אוקיי, אז זה דוגמה לזה. זה GPT.
אוקיי, GPT models הם כאלה. הם recorder only. נמשיך לדבר על זה אחרי ההפסקה.
דוגמה ל another only part ודוגמה ל encounter recorder.
זה נגיד מה שדיברנו שבוע שעבר Transformer ים לתרגום.
כן. טוב, אז בואו נצא לרבע שעה הפסקה ונחזור.
זה בעצם הבן של סטודנטים של הבן שלי.
על כולם, על כולם. כן. בהקשר שלנו אולי גם אתה לא תעשה כן.
היום זה נהיה פרקטיקה דיפלומטית, שגם כאן אולי צריך להוסיף קישורים, אבל אתה צריך לעשות משהו קצת כאילו טוב הוא בהחלט מוזר.
זה יצא באמת תקין וברצון כן, זה קטע, אבל זה לא הארכיטקטורה הזאת.
כן כן, נגיד, אם תרצה לתרגם לידי ביטוי אז הוא יצטרך.
אם תרצה לתרגם הוא יצטרך לעשות משהו פה עקום, שהוא באמת שם אופטימלי,
אבל אולי לא כזה אכפת לך כי הרשת שלך מספיק חזקה ואתה לא רוצה שזה לעשות דברים מהסוג הזה.
אתה משלם עבור תרגום במכירות, אבל כאילו להאזין לו אתה יכול להאזין,
להגיד אפשר להגיד הנה משפט ביפנית לתרגם אותו לאנגלית כי זה מסתדר טוב, לא משנה בקונטקסט.
לא, יש לו עדיין את הקונטקסט. אולי זו שאלה טובה. בוא תשאל אותי על זה אחרי ההפסקה.
אני רוצה גם לענות לך על השאלה הזו. תגיד לי אתה צריך?
לסדר את זה נכון? נכון? כן כן, אתה רוצה.
כמה זמן אתה צריך להתעסק עם זה? אתם שואלים? כן, אבל היום אני חייב למצוא פתרון לפני שיהיה מאוחר.
כמובן שהמצב ישתפר. כן, אני רוצה פנים אל פנים וזה כאילו שיש לך את זה מושלם.
האמת שאני נמצא עכשיו גם בטלפון. זה לא יהיה פשוט.
כאילו אתה לא מבין. בוא נראה איך.
זה. אבל לפני זה אתה יכול לדבר אפילו על הדברים האלה, על זה שאתה לא יצא מהארון.
מן הסתם לא אדבר על דברים שאני עושה שם. כן. על מה אתה מדבר?
על הרושם הכללי של העשייה? כן כן, זה אני יכול לדבר הרבה.
אני מן הסתם לא אדבר ספציפית על התוכניות העסקיות שלהם. כן, בטח.
תראה, אם אני שאלתי שאלות שאני אגיד שאני לא יכול לענות. זה בשבילי זה סוף.
דבר. אני רוצה לדבר מחר בשלוש.
אפשר בערב? הראשון? מתי בערב שישי בערב.
נגיד שיש בבוקר בשישי בערב. תמיד חשבתי על זה.
זה לא כזה פשוט להתקשר אליך. כן בבקשה. יאללה מגניב.
תודה. ואם אתה רוצה עכשיו לדבר אתה יודע שאתה מרגיש כאילו אתה עושה את זה.
אני רציתי לשאול נדמה לי משהו שקשור באופנה. אני לא רוצה לדבר איתך.
לא אכפת לי שיש לך בעיה קשה. אני לא שם. זה בסדר?
יש לך משהו שהוא ברמה הכי גבוהה? תשובה לעניין.
כן. שירי האלבום הזה אתה מנסה לצאת לפנסיה?
זה היה טעות. את כל הברכות שלא הצלחתי לעשות שהבנתי את המחשבות שלך.
אתה רוצה להיות נשיא ארהב? מה הסרט? מה הוא עושה?
זה בסדר? הייתי מחכה לו איזה שבוע שבוע 6.
מה עושים עם? זה?
ברוך השם החלטתי. בואו נניח שאי אפשר שום דבר.
מה עושים עם זה? אני ממש. לא הייתי.
הבנתי שחייבים לשלם סכום כלשהו.
כל מערכת השרירים של ישראל. זה כמו Gmail.
זה לא חדש. כן, אבל השאלה היא האם.
אתה זוכר את השנה החדשה?
זה לא שיש כאן אימון עסקי, אבל זה מה שכתבתי כאן.
יש כאן חלק של המלך, של כל שאר המפלגות.
פשוט לא הבנתי את הקושי הרב. האמת שהייתי אומר בכל הכבוד לנרטיבים שאני יוצא בתוכם.
זה בעצם בתכלס מודל מערכות עם טיפוסים. זה לפי מה שאני רוצה לדעת את העובדות.
תיאורטית יכול גם לעבוד על המילים הדבר הזה.
כן, למרות שזה כנראה לא המצב מאוד טובה. אז. נכון שבכללי קשה להוציא לו צ'ק אין.
הבעלים הקודם כועס על ה כאילו שהתחוללה בלתי צפויה בכל מה שקדם בהינתן הלייזר.
כן, אז הבנתי, ובעצם בדרך כלל הרעיון שאני מקבל משפט, או אז אני מנסה להבין את הלייבלים שלו ואני יכול.
או שאפילו מספיק שיקבל פסטיבל אחד ואז מספיק כמה לייבלים ואז הוא יתברך שם גם את ליבי.
וכמובן זה סוג של אני הייתי גם מבצע Cnf.
הוא זורק את ההנחה שהחבילה שהם בעצם הלייבל לא כותבים לו,
והוא רוצה ליצור איזושהי פונקציית מאפיינים על קול שמבוסס על כל הקונטקסט בעצם ואז הוא פועל ואז יש לשאול שאלה.
הייתי רוצה לרדת על הוקוס פוקוס. סליחה שאני מקבל את זה.
אז בשיא הקיץ מה שקורה זה באמת מזכיר לי.
שזה כבר עבר. ובעצם ההנחה שלו שהעתיד שלך נשען על משפט מתפרק בסכום של פיצ'ר פאנצ'ים.
אגיד את זה, בא לי גם CRM של פיצ'ר חדשני שלא רק עובדים על זוגות צמחים ושרימפס.
זה בעצם אתה אומר, זה משחק כזה. אתה מבין את אקספרסיביות של הפיצ'ר החדש שלך?
בעצם הדרך שבה אתה נותן Score לאיזושהי סדרה של ביזנס יכולה להיות תלויה רק כאילו כל גורם חיבורי יכול להיות דומה מאד לזוג סדרה של קורס ואז תולדות המשפחה.
בהנחה המופשטת הזו, אתה עכשיו יכול להשתמש בפיטר פן כדי לעשות כן, כי אתה יודע לעשות חידונים?
לא יודע בדיוק, וגם מה שאתה יכול בעצם לחשב באופן מדויק את האנגלית.
טוב. אז נעשה כל מה שאתה צריך. זה כאילו תגובה של למידה כדי לנסות להבין את הפונקציות.
מאפיינים כמו כדי איזה משקל של מידע זה על אשכולות?
כן כן, הפילוסופיה שלו. נניח שהוא טוב, אז תיאורטית אני סתם זורק את הפריט.
זה יכול ממש למשל להשתמש בתפקיד של חג שבועות כאילו זה היה מעביר אותה, ואז כל מה שהוא עושה זה רק לתת את זה,
לשנות את המשקולות של כל סוג, של Function בתהליך של רמז, של כל feature.
כן אין צורך בכל feature. זה ממש שזה ממש ממש אמיתי כזה.
איפשהו זה שם מדריך ליניארי. אתה יכול לעשות פולינומי בקלות תוסיפי מכפלות, אבל לא לפרופורציה.
כי בלי פיצ'ר פאשן הציפייה מהפיד שלך כבר ימצא את האינטראקציה.
כל מה שאתה צריך זה משפיע. סבבה. עד שהבנתי את זה רגע לפני כן שיש לי בקוביה לאחר מכן, מעבר לפוסט הבא, פוטנציאל של נסיעה לאחור.
אתה לא חייב. אתה יכול לשאול הכל טוב נכון? אתה יכול כן לנקות את זה קודם?
למה לא? בוא נגיד שאתה ממש רוצה. לא עושה פה את המצב כי זה בעצם טקסט מסוג אחר.
אני נתתי את הדוגמה של תקצוב. זאת אומרת שיש לך טקסט שנכנס טקסט בעברית של מטוס חוזר וגם האוטובוס הוא טקסט בעברית של טקסט אחר קצת.
יותר משנה וחצי וגם טיפש ראשון יש את זה קודם.
אה רגע, אתה עכשיו מדבר על חזית הבניין ברחוב?
נכון, עכשיו אמרת שאתה יכול להיות בטוח איך זה כבר יסתדר לי?
אבל קודם כל זה יכול להיות טקסט נכון? אוקיי, וגם פה יש טקסט.
למה? כמו פרצוף משפטי? כן.
רגע. עכשיו מה שאני ציירתי כאן זה כאילו סקיצות. כן אתה.
עכשיו נחזור לשאלה שלך מה אני עושה כאן? אתה נמצא כאן בביקורת Online או בעקבות בדיקות בביקורת עירונית.
אוקיי, רגע. בסדר, אני חשבתי שאתה כאן. טקסט?
ביקורת דרכונים? כן. זה פשוט. ושוטפים את האוקיינוס.
ואז בעצם זה בדיוק מה שנשאר. שאל אותי לפני ההפסקה.
עכשיו נדבר על זה. בדיוק על השאלה הזאת זה קצת מבלבל.
איך אתה יכול להשתמש? אמרתי את זה.
אני בסוף זה משפטי וזה זה.
כרטיסים בבקשה. זה משפט, זה לא חוקי.
זה נכון. צריך לעבור לצורה של טוב כדי לבצע את הטכניקה הזאת.
כן, אז זה לא נחשב. בכל מקרה זה לא עבד. זה לא כל הזמן המרחק ממה שהתכוונתי זה זז.
טוב. אני אחזור על זה. התשובה שלך כנראה לא.
כנראה לא אמרתי את זה, אבל אני אחזור על זה שוב. מקווה שזה ברור ואם לא אז תרימי את הטקסט.
זה שווה לגמרי. זה בחינם, זה שווה לגמרי כי אתה כזה קורבן שלך.
הוא בעצם לא מה שקרה אותו רגרסיבי כאילו הוא הוא בעצם מה שפשוט מחזיר סדרה של בקבוקים.
אתה לא מזיז את האוטובוס לפאריס?
נראה לי שאני פשוט אחזור לחקור את זה בצורה מסודרת. עכשיו אתה יכול באותו רגע לכתוב את המוח?
כן, אתה קשור לזה. הבנתי את זה.
כבר לא זוכר עדיין איך זה קרה. אני מצטער, אני אכתוב על זה.
זה לא מושך אותי, זה לא עושה את זה.
אני אסביר, עכשיו אני אעשה את זה יותר מסוכן.
אני מבין שזה לא בסדר. כן. זה?
בסדר. אבל אז.
זה? אני מרגיש שהבית שלנו.
נועד. לעשות סדר קטן.
כדי להבין. אותך?
למי זה מתאים? אוקיי, כולם חזרו.
כן. כן.
כן. טוב. טוב, אז אני אעשה קצת סדר.
הבנתי מהשאלות שעלו שזה קצת לא ברור וגם הייתה שאלה מהקהל.
מי שאל אותי כאן בהפסקה? אה, לא משנה.
אוקיי, אז ככה. בוא אני אעשה את זה בצורה קצת יותר מפורטת.
אולי זה יותר ברור. טוב, אז יש את ארכיטקטורת another disorder.
זה Transformer כפי שהכרנו אותו. למדנו בשיעור הקודם בפרוטרוט על כל החלקים שלו.
אוקיי, זה השיעור הקודם. כמו Translation, אבל בעצם כפי שציינתי פעם שווה.
לא חייבים להשתמש בו דווקא למשל translation. אפשר להשתמש בו גם למשימות אחרות?
כן, אבל מה שמשותף להן זה שיש בדרך כלל איזשהו קלט קבוע מסוים נתון, ואנחנו רוצים לייצר ממנו כן או לייצר.
בהינתן התקן, בהינתן הטקסט הנתון הזה, אנחנו רוצים לייצר איזשהו טקסט חדש, נגיד, למשל תרגום זה דוגמה לזה.
דוגמה אחרת לזה זה תקצוב. כן, אני רוצה טקסט ארוך.
להכניס ב input ולהוציא טקסט קצר ב output. פישוט משפטים כן.
או משהו שעושה פרפראזה או או מתקן שגיאות סגנוניות או כל מיני דברים.
אוקיי, אז זה Another. מה שחשוב לזכור כאן זה מה ה output שלו.
אוקיי, אז זה output שבגדול של Oder הוא פשוט עם Padding.
כן vector אחד עבור כל מילה האינפוט נכון.
Output של הדיכאון.
בדרך כלל אנחנו מסתכלים פשוט על ה output של המילה האחרונה שלא מנוסחת כן, כי כל השאר נשארים קבועים בין איטרציה ל איטרציה ואנחנו מפרשים אותה.
כן, בהינתן שיש לנו פה איזשהו Classification Head שהוא בגודל אוצר המילים, כן,
שהוא בעצם נותן התפלגות על פני אוצר המילים אנחנו מפרשים את ה output של הרשת.
אז מה שהרשת הזאת פולטת פה זה התפלגות על.
אם נגיד שה input זה X1 עד x אין לה output fix זה y עד y אם.
כן אז ההסתברות. של y m פלוס אחד בהינתן.
X1 עד איקס אם. Y אחד עד y אין בסדר ואז אפשר לעשות באמצעות זה Insurance בשיטות שלמדנו לעשות grid Insurance, שזה מה אומר.
לבחור בעצם את השכיח פה. כן את ה y ממקסם את ההתפלגות או לעשות bin search.
אבל בגדול לפעמים קוראים למודלים האלה מודלים סיקוונס טו סיקוונס, למרות שזה שם לא כל כך מוצלח.
כן?
למה חושבים עליהם כסיכון סיקוונס, למרות שכל מה שהם פולטים זה פשוט התפלגות על פני המילה הבאה, בגלל שגם לוקחים בחשבון את ה Inferno שבכל שלב בוחר מילה,
מזין אותה חזרה לדי קודר באמצעותה בוחר עוד מילה, מזין אותה חזרה לתיק Cover חרות, מילה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
כן. אז בעצם זאת הסיבה, אבל זה תהליך שלא קורה כבר על ידי הרשת.
כן, זה איזשהו לופ חיצוני. נכון שאם רפרנס שמבצעים עליה אוקיי, לפעמים אגב, גם קוראים לזה auto אגרסיב מודל auto אגרסיב הכוונה היא בדיוק לזה.
זאת אומרת, לאו דווקא ל encounter recorder. לכל מודל שמזין את ה output שלו מהאינטראקציה הקודמת חזרה כן חזרה לתוכו בשביל לייצר את הפרדיגמה הבאה.
אז זה anchor text decoration. שאלה האם אתה קורא עירוני?
לגמרי נכון. נכון? נכון? שנייה אחת.
דבר דבר האם code on line? לא. כן, שנייה לא.
לא הולכת קדימה. הנקודה רון לי כל הזמן נשבר.
אולי זאת פירמה יותר טובה? יש שם מלא טיעונים. יש שם מלא טיעונים.
זה נראה לי יותר דחוס. אוקיי, בוא ננסה.
אז Another only או another only?
בסדר, מה הוא עושה? הוא מקבל איזשהו INPUT נכון?
איזשהו input X1 עד x n. אוקיי.
אז הוא מקבל כן input. כן Token.
X1. נכון?
ומה הוא פולט? בדיוק?
בדיוק. הוא בעצם Encounter only models. השאלה אם מחשיבים אותו עם ה classification head או בלי.
אבל באופן עקרוני ה output של ה another עצמו זה פשוט וקטורים עם bad things של הטור.
כן עם האלה V אחד עד x n נגיד כן קראנו להם context עם Padding.
אוקיי, ולפעמים על גבי זה שמים Classification head.
נכון? כי אנחנו רוצים לעשות משהו עם הווקטורים האלה. זה במהלך ה pre training יש classification head שהוא פשוט מכפלה במטריצה ו soft max.
נכון? ובזמן ה פיקציה ב fine tuning מה שלא עשינו איזה Classification שהרכבנו עשה בסדר אז זה include only.
In האינוורטר האנגלי. הוא פשוט עובד כמו הטרנספורטר Encounter. כלומר הוא עושה בית על אקשן אמיתי.
עכשיו only הוא גם אותו רגע, אז זה אותו אגרסיב לא נכון?
לא אותו אגרסיב. הוא פשוט פולט משהו. זהו הדיכאון האנגלי.
הוא מאוד דומה ל encounter disorder רק שאין הפרדה בין input ולבין presence.
אוקיי, אז עכשיו האינפוט של דר Online הוא פשוט Token.
X1 עד X אין וארט פוט.
זה בדרך כלל בוא נאמר ככה זה פשוט איזשהו וקטור שיוצא מהדיכאון.
דר כן, שאנחנו בדרך כלל מפרשים אותו, מכפילים אותו במטריצה בסוף מקס.
אז אפשר אולי לומר זה n עם padding.
או input. ובדרך כלל יש איזשהו classification heads כן לאיזשהו שכבה לינארית בסוף מקס לדוגמה,
שמה שהיא פולטת אנחנו מפרשים אותו בהתפלגות על פני אוצר המילים אוקיי, אז After.
Linear פלוס soft max.
Layer אז זה Interpretation. As p של x אין פלוס אחד בהינתן איקס אחד.
אוקיי, עכשיו הייתה נכון שאלה ששאלת אותי בהפסקה, אה עוד לפני השאלה של ההפסקה.
אוקיי. בין אם זה וקטור אחד שמייצג את כל ה.
בדרך כלל כי אמרו באופן עקרוני לכל אינפוט, גם כאן לכל אינפוט יש וקטור שיוצא.
כן, לא רק זה כאילו זה כאילו V של איקס אין נכון.
כאילו ה output במקום של של איקס אין. כן, אבל באחרים אתה בדרך כלל לא מתעניין בדרך כלל.
כי כשאתה מפעיל את זה אוטו רגרסיבית, ואז כל פעם כשאתה מזין אפס בפרי FX אתה מתעניין.
בראשון, כשאתה מזין פרי פיקס בגודל 1, אתה מתעניין בעצם במקום הבא.
כשאתה מזהים פרי פיקס באורך 2 אתה תיתן מקום הבא. האחרים לא משתנים באופן עקרוני זו סדרה של ו.
זה קצת שאלה על מה אתה מסתכל? כן, אוקיי.
עכשיו היו עוד שאלות. כן, לך הייתה שאלה בהפסקה תחזור עליה? התשובה שלי.
אנחנו דורשים בדיקות דם. ברור לי שהוא לא מסתכל על כל הכיוונים.
כן? איך אני יכול להשתמש בו לתרגום?
אוקיי, יפה. אז השאלה איך בכל זאת אפשר להשתמש? נגיד אנחנו אמרתי לכם ש GPT הוא disorders only, אבל אתם מכירים את GPT אולי?
ונגיד אתם יודעים לעשות איתו למשל תרגום? כן. אז אוקיי, אבל דיברנו על איך עושים תרגומים Encounter Recorder.
מה קורה פה? בדיקות דר און לירי בדיקות דר אונלי? הכל זה אותו דבר.
נכון, יש פה שוק Token. גם Fix וגם האינפוט הם אותו הדבר.
כן. אז מה בעצם אני עושה? מה שאני עושה כאן זה בעצם אני גם חושב על בעיית התרגום.
אני חושב עליה כבעיה של language Modeling. אוקיי, בעצם הרעיון הוא שאני מחליף את הכל לבעיות של להשלים משפט.
ואם תשימו לב פחות או יותר כל בעיה אתם יכולים. כל בעיה טקסטואלית אתם יכולים לנסח ככה.
שנייה. כן, כל בעיה טקסטואלית אתם יכולים לנסח ככה.
אם יש לכם שאלה כמה גדולה צרפת? כן, אז אתם יכולים לכתוב Pre fix know how big and friends a נקודותיים תשלים כן או Document ו Summary?
אתם יכולים פשוט לקחת את ה Document, לשרשר אותו עם הפרויקט של ה Summary ולכסות את המילה הבאה ואז להמשיך או במקרה של תרגום.
כן ברכה של תרגום ששאלת אותי. אתה יכול גם לכתוב key ה how do I translate.
לא יודע. בוקר טוב from Hebrew to whatever is a.
נקודותיים תשלים אם אתה צריך.
לעבוד בעצם למשימה של פרויקטים. כן, אז זה כאילו מכאן מגיע כל המושג של Prompt Thing.
כן, Prompt thing זה איכשהו לנסח את הבעיה, ככה שהתשובה שלה תהיה פשוט להמשיך את הטקסט.
כן, לפחות זה היה Prompt הראשוני. מאז זה גם עבר קצת גלגולים.
נדבר עליהם, אבל זה לפחות הרעיון הבסיסי של Prompt. עכשיו האם זה שקול?
לא, זה לא שקול. כן, זה לא שקול. למה זה לא שקול? כי בוא כן, בוא נחשוב על זה שנייה.
אם אתם עכשיו מתרגמים איזשהו משפט, נגיד כמו המשפט שלנו, אז בוקר טוב.
זה קצת נראה לי זה קל. כן, אבל בוא נגיד ש how do I translate ואז אתה עושה שם פייסט של אני לא יודע מה מלחמה ושלום כן בעברית.
ואתה שואל אני לא יודע מה זו שפה אחרת. אולי יום מלחמה ושלום כי זה כבר טקסט מתורגם, אבל טקסט בעברית התנך כן.
ואז אתה. אוקיי, סתם אני לוקח דוגמה קצת מופרכת. כן, אבל אבל.
אבל באופן עקרוני טקסט שלא קל לתרגם אותו. כן, זה לא פשוט שליפה של איזשהו ביטוי.
אז מה בעצם קורה הדיכאון The only model. נכון, הוא כל פעם מקודד מילה רק בהסתמך על המילים שקדמו לה,
ולכן אנחנו צריכים שהוא יהיה מספיק טוב כדי שלמרות שהוא בעצם פוטנציאלית לא עושה שימוש אופטימלי בפריים FX, בכל זאת הוא יצליח לתרגם אותו כמו שצריך.
למה הוא לא עושה שימוש אופטימלי? כי כדי לייצג מילה באיזשהו מובן הוא חייב רק להסתכל אחורה.
אז אם הוא רוצה, אם יש משהו קדימה שמשפיע על הניתוח של המילה הוא איכשהו needs to figure it out.
בעצם מתוך החישובים שהוא כבר עשה קודם. עכשיו זה לא שזה בלתי אפשרי, כי המכונות האלה הן כל כך אקספרסיביות שעקרונית הוא nos.
כן. למה לא כן?
כנראה שיש להם מספיק אקספרסיביות כדי כדי גם להצליח לעשות סוג של תיקון עצמי אם הם ייצגו משהו לא כמו שצריך, לדעת להתעלם ממנו ואולי לנתח את זה מחדש.
אבל על פניו זה שימוש תת אופטימלי. כן, מה שמרוויחים.
מצד שני, בזה שאנחנו מתעסקים בדיכאון, בראוניז פרטיטורה יותר פשוטה.
כן. למה היא יותר פשוטה? א. היא לא מכילה עוד בלוק שלם שקראנו לו Encounter נכון?
ב. היא לא מכילה פה את ה קומפוננטה השנייה שעושה cross attention.
כן, שבעצם מסתכלת גם שעושה attention גם על הווקטורים של הפרי פיקס של ה mask self attention וגם על הוקטורים שיצאו מהאין Cover.
זה יש רק שנייה אחת. זה ענה על השאלה שלך. כן. אוקיי, אז אנחנו אומרים שהשיטה הזו של כאילו זה גם שם מאוד מסובך למשהו מאוד חשוב וזה פורום ייעוץ עסקי.
אין לך חיים פרטיים באוטו מאסטרינג והמשימה היא מיידית.
בתוך הספרינט הזה אתה יכול לעשות הכללה של כל המשימות שעבדת עד כה.
תרגום ואפילו פוסטים על בסיס אתה יכול כזה סאן טיימס.
שמתם לב? כל דבר בדיוק? כל מה שאתה יכול. עקרונית, כל מה שאתה יכול לנסח בשפה טבעית.
אתה השאלה שלי. אז בעצם עשינו הכללה של משימות שהיו יותר אופטימליות בהפרדה בין המקומי לקהל זה.
עשינו הכללה למה לא לעשות אותה הכללה ולהשתמש ואין כל מלאכה או בדק.
אוקיי, אז בוא נחשוב למה לא להשתמש? למה לא להשתמש בין קודר אונלי להכל?
מה החיסרון של Another only love של לונדון? זה ממש שהוא לא מה שהוא מאוד לא מתאים לג'יימס בונד.
אוקיי, נכון, כי מה בעצם? כי הוא מסתכל על הכל ומוציא התפלגות על הכל ורואה את העתיד.
וכן, בהנחה שהוא לא רואה את העתיד כי מי יכול לראות את העתיד?
אז כאילו מה? דורון? הם פשוט מריצים אותו על האינפוט שיש לנו נכון?
ואז אתה מקבל איזו שהיא פרי דיקציה, ואין כאן עניין של מין פרי פיקס שהולך ומתארך, שבעזרתו אתה כן מייצר סיטואציה.
אבל למה פוגעת? מה? מה אני מקבל? מי להעיף את הקטעים קודם?
כאילו בסדר, הראית לי שאפשר להתייחס ארכיטקטורה יותר פשוטה לשותף.
כן כן. אוקיי. עוד שאלות כן.
האם כשאנחנו מדברים על code Online זה בהכרח בלי פרומואים?
לא, אתה לא. כאילו אתה יודע שאלה Prompt Thing זה בעצם איזשהו שם שקראו לאיך אתה מנסח את הפרי פיקס.
בעצם, איך זה נראה? כן? איך זה נראה?
נכון, יש לך איזושהי משימה? כן, קומפקטי מאוד ב high level.
כן מאוד. ב high level. מה זה אומר? יש לך איזושהי משימה שאתה רוצה לפתור?
אתה רוצה להשתמש בשבילה ב language model נכון?
מה זה אומר Prompt Prompt? זה אומר לכתוב איזשהו טקסט שאני אוכל להזין כ input model, ככה שמתוך ה output אני אדע לקרוא את מה שרציתי,
בין אם זה טקסט מגונדרת או קלאסית, פיקציה או מה שזה לא יהיה.
כן, אז. אז אני חושב די השימוש הסטנדרטי בזה כי זה פשוט מילה מאוד מאוד כוללנית.
כן. סליחה על השאלה, אבל אם אני עושה כאילו זה באמת אוטומטית,
אבל אם אני עושה משהו שזה לא בהכרח עושה ניקוד עירוני, אז מה ההבדל בין זה לבין לבדוק את זה סתם על איזה טקסט?
כאילו יש לי דרך להעריך תיקון אייפון בלי מודל, מבלי לתת לו איזה מקום, כי בעצם אני בודק את זה.
או שאני מבולבל. לא הגדרתי פורמלית מה זה Prompt, כי אני חושב שאין בדיוק הגדרה פורמלית, אבל אני חושב שלפעמים.
עזוב, אפשר לקרוא פשוט לפרי fix בהקשר של Decor the only model.
אפשר לקרוא לזה פשוט Prompt. כן, הסיבה שלפעמים לא קוראים לה fix prompt זה סיבות מאוד טכניות כאלה שלמשל אם אתה כן יש לך,
נגיד למשל אולי חלק ב Prompt שבו כאילו שבו אתה מנסח את הבעיה שהמודל רוצה שהוא מודל צריך לפתור,
אבל לפעמים אתה גם מכניס לזה קונטקסט של איזשהו משהו שהוא אמור להסתמך עליו, ואז לפעמים אתה לא קורא לזה חלק Prompt,
או לפעמים יש בתוך זה גם את הפרי Fix שכבר יצרת, כי אז עכשיו כל פעם מרים מזין אותו.
אוטו רגרסיבי, נכון? אז מה שיצרת גם נכנס פנימה לתוך האינפוט.
אז אתה לא מחשיב את זה חלק מהפרויקט. אתה מחשיב את זה כבר כחלק מה Output אז?
אז זה עניין שפשוט הגדרות. אתה יודע, אין כאן משהו מעניין.
זה פשוט הגדרות טכניות. כן, אבל בגדול Prompt זה בדיוק השיטה הזאת שמה שהיא אומרת זה אני.
אכתוב משהו למודל. כך שה output של language model יפתור את הבעיה שממנה יצאו.
כן זה זה כל כל הרעיון. הרעיון סך הכל מאוד פשוט.
אוקיי. כן. בהקשר של מודל קוד היו ניסיונות לבנות מודל שפה גדול שזה יכול לקרות כמה דברים.
כן כן, כן, עשו דברים כאלה. באיזשהו שלב הפסיקו כי זה לא נתן מספיק תועלת לעומת כמות הפרמטרים שהקדשת לזה.
אבל כן היו כל מיני ניסיונות לעשות כל מיני דברים.
כמו כן, אז השאלה מה היה? מהו הפרי טריינינג שלך בהקשר הזה, נכון?
אז עשו למשל דברים שקוראים לזה construction lose. כן, שהרעיון שם זה שאתה לוקח את ה input אתה איכשהו פוגם בו.
Correction somewhere mask זה אחד הדרכים to correct טקסט, אבל זה גם יכול להחליף את הסדר של המילים,
למחוק חלקים בלי להשאיר מסק כאילו אלא סתם למחוק אותם וכן הלאה ולבקש ממנו לחזור את הטקסט המקורי מתוך זה.
אז זה נגיד או בעיה דומה? סך הכל זה הכל בני דודים אחד של השני.
כן, אבל זה נגיד פורמלית שמתאימה לנקודת Recorder לעומת Mask Language, מודל שהאינפורמציה שיותר מתאימה להם Control.
אוקיי. בסדר, אחלה.
עכשיו מה שגם רציתי להגיד זה שגם disorder only models אפשר לעשות להם fine tuning.
זה לא השימוש הפופולרי שלהם. כן, אבל רק פשוט רציתי להזכיר את זה כדי שלא נסיים את הדיון תחת הרושם שכשאין fine tuning.
זה קורה עם Encounter only models וכן רפטינג או כן או עם קונטקסט learning.
זה קורה עם The Only models. בהחלט כן.
האחד. שניהם יכולים לעבור fine tuning ובאמצעות שניהם אפשר לעשות עם קונטקסט learning.
כן, אז רק אני מזכיר את זה בגדול.
השיטות משתנות בין אחת לשנייה כאילו השיטות הספציפיות, אבל בדרך כלל נרצה להשתמש ב fine tuning של ביקורת The only models.
אם דיקציה שלנו היא הדיקציה ברמת הטקסט או ברמת המשפט, כאילו לא ברמה של מילים בודדות.
והסיבה לזה היא בדיוק מה שאמרנו קודם. כן, נגיד אתם. יש לכם עכשיו משפט שלם.
כן, כמו נגיד ריוויו לסרט. דוגמה פשוטה This movie terrible.
כן, אולי זה משהו יותר ארוך. אתם רוצים לחזות לגביו מה זה נגיד סנטימנט נכון?
מה זה מתבקש? כן, אתם רוצים לחזות את הסנטימנט של זה?
אז אוקיי, אז יש לכם בסוף איזשהו איזשהו דיקציה.
נכון שהיא עושה בעצם איזשהו חישוב שהוא עושה Attention על כל העוקבים הקודמים,
אז זה מתקבל על הדעת לבנות על גביו Classification head שאחרי זה אפשר גם לעשות לו fine tuning ל סנטימנט analysis לדוגמה.
אוקיי, אבל אם הפרויקט שלכם הוא ברמת המילים אז זה חייב להיות פרדיגמה שמסתכלת רק אחורה.
נכון? כי אם ברמת המילים מודל כזה, מטבע הדברים לא יוכל לקחת בחשבון את מה שלפניו,
אז זה מגביל את השיטות, את השיחה, את אוסף הבעיות שאפשר לעבוד עליהן, אבל זה גם קיים.
אוקיי, שאלות לגבי זה זה יחסית ברור איך אתם מבחינת החומר של השיעור,
אז אני יודע שזה היה קצת הבנתי בהפסקה שזה היה מבלבל קצת לפרקים ופחות או יותר אישרנו קו או שיש עדיין.
אוקיי, בסדר. כן, וזה בגדול מסכם את מה שאמרתי קודם.
יפה. אז מה זה large language modules?
כן, דיברנו על language models ודיברנו על על. כן ודיברנו על כל מיני סוגים.
Big גרם tri גרם וארנון base ודי code only וכן הלאה.
אבל מה זה large? Language models או elements? אז בגדול אין לזה גם שם יותר מסחרי מאשר מדעי.
אבל בגדול, מה שהשם בא לציין שבעצם עברנו איזשהו מעבר פאזה בכמה שנים האלה.
נגיד בין כן 2018 2017, כשהתחילו המודלים שהם כבר יש להם מודלים,
שפה שכבר יש להם איזשהו כמות מאוד משמעותית של פרמטרים שנכון ל 2018 זה היה סדר גודל של 100 מיליון.
כן. ואז ראינו שבמהלך אגב, זה במידה מסוימת נעצר גם כן מגיע לאיזושהי לא בדיוק רוויה, אבל כאילו עברו קצת לאפיקים אחרים.
אבל כן, היו כמה שנים שבהם ממש מה שאנחנו רואים זה קצב גידול אקספוננציאלי.
כן, זה מספר הפרמטרים. ומספר הפרמטרים במיליארדים.
כן, אז רואים את GPT 2 בתחילת 2019.
לפניו היה עוד BRT. כן Alma הוא היה 100 מיליון BRT.
הציע מה שקראו אז brt large.
כן, היה 340 מיליון פרמטרים GPT 2 שזה היה המודל הראשון של open ai שבאמת קרה גלים עוד לפני קצת לפני ה GPT 3 היה לו מיליארד וחצי.
אחרי זה היה מגהטרון T5 של גוגל עם קצת הבדלים ביניהם.
כן, היו כל מיני וריאנטים. בגדול GPT 3 נתן כפי שאתם רואים, קפיצה אפילו מעבר לקו המגמה אקספוננציאלי.
אז GPT 3 באמת היה הרבה יותר גדול ממה שכמה שהשתמשו קודם.
משהו כמו סדר גודל יותר גדול. הוא היה 175 מיליארד פרמטרים.
מאז עוד הגדילו את זה לאזור ה טריליונים. באיזשהו שלב זה כבר נהיה זה כבר.
א. מקבלים פחות מהגדלת ב. כמות הדאטה שזמינה אפילו למפלצות.
הדאטה האלה היא בכל זאת באיזושהי רמה מוגבלת.
וכן, באיזשהו שלב זה די נעצר ואז הלכו קצת לכיוונים אחרים או לכיוונים של מודלים גדולים, אבל שרק חלק מהם עובר אקטיבציה בכל איטרציה נתונה.
דברים האלה אתם תלמדו. מי שייקח Advanced NLP אני לא רוצה להרחיב על זה יותר, אבל זאת בעצם המילה LM באה בדיוק לתאר את המעבר הזה שרבים רואים בו מעבר פאזה.
כן, מדברים בגודל של מיליונים.
כן? או אולי במקרה הקיצוני 100 מיליון, למרות שגם זה משהו מאוד גדול לזמנו.
אבל סדרי הגודל האלה לסדרי גודל של טריליונים כן, אחרי כמה שנים בודדות.
אוקיי. בסדר, אז אני חושב דיברנו על זה.
אלה פה עוד דוגמאות. מי שירצה אחרי זה להסתכל על זירו שטליה.
אני לקחתי עוד דוגמה.
אוקיי, ואז זה מביא אותנו ל GPT 3, אזור 2020, שבגדול אלה שיטות שמבוססות על אותן שיטות של טכנולוגית זה פשוט מאמר ה Transformer מ 2017.
תן שם ליזול יוניט. עם קצת שיפצורים ובעיקר העלאה דרמטית בסקאלה.
כן, העלאה דרמטית, העלאה של משהו כמו שלושה סדרי גודל בין המאמר הראשון של ה Transformer לבין שלושה ואפילו קצת יותר.
לבין לבין GPT 3. אוקיי, אבל זה באמת מוביל אותנו לסוף 2020, וזה עדיין לא מה שאתם מכירים.
כי שם עוד בעצם המילה language model עברה עוד שינוי משמעותי שמה שנקרא Instruction Models או Instruction מודפס.
אז מה הרעיון ב instruction models? זה בעצם יהיה הנושא.
זה יהיה הנושא הבא שלנו. בעצם הרעיון כאן אומר תראו, אם אני עכשיו אכניס Prompt ל GPT 3.
אוקיי, נגיד למשל Explain the moon landing to the world in a few sentence.
אוקיי, ואבקש ממנו להשלים. אוקיי, זה appreciate prompt.
ועכשיו תייצר competition. אז מה הוא יעשה? יכול להיות שהוא ייצר Exploration אבל בדרך כלל זה לא מה שהוא יעשה בכלל, אלא הוא ימשיך לייצר ויגיד.
Explain the theory of gravity to explain the theory of the world in the big bang theory to explain evolution to us.
עכשיו כל ההשלמות האלה הן לא שמות גרועות במובן זה, שכן אם אתם שואלים עכשיו יש לי טקסט בטקסט.
נכון, זה בעצם מה ששאלנו אותו. אתם רואים עכשיו? יש לי טקסט בטקסט כתוב למעלה Explained המון.
Landing to exist world in a few sentence. אוקיי.
מהי השורה הבאה? השורות האלה הן בהחלט שורות מתקבלות על הדעת.
כן. למה לא? אולי נגיד למשל זה דף שהוא דף?
לא יודע. דוגמאות לשאלות. סמינר מורים מקורס בסמינר מורים.
אוקיי, אז הנה, יש לי כל מיני דוגמאות. או אולי זה בכלל משפט שהופיע בטקסט על פרה פרזות?
כן, ואז הוא לא יודע. אולי הוא מנסח דברים די דומה או משהו כזה.
מי יודע בכלל? כן. זאת אומרת, אין שום סיבה לחשוב שההמשך של הוראה במובן הזה של כן.
The most likely כן compilation the most likely Continuum של טקסט נתון תהיה מענה על ההוראה הזו.
נכון, בהחלט יכול להיות שזה יהיה עוד הוראות, או אולי סתם אפילו טקסט לא לגמרי קשור, כי לפעמים זה גם קורה.
נכון. יש משפט ואז משפט הבא הוא כל כך קשור אליו אז.
אבל מה שהיינו רוצים כן, וזה בעצם מה שהם טענו בפניי שהם השיגו באינטרנט באינטרנט GPT שזה נחשב משהו כמו זה היה איזשהו Processor לצ'אט GPT.
כן, בעצם מה שהם אמרו זה. תנסח את זה אתה תנסח את ה Prompt כהוראה בדיוק כמו כאן.
אבל אנחנו נדאג להבין למה התכוונת ולענות על זה.
אוקיי, שתשימו לב זה לא אותו דבר כמו להשלים טקסט.
כן, זאת לא אותה משימה. אז פיפל.
אז נגיד, היינו רוצים משהו כמו People went to the moon and I took pictures of the day to send me back to the earth, so we all could be seen.
אוקיי, אז זה כאילו הרעיון בצ'אט באינטרנט Models וזה בעצם הכיוון שהתחום לקח מאז, ואת זה אנחנו תכף נדבר עליו כשנדבר על פוסט סטרימינג.
אבל לפני שנעשה את זה, אני רוצה שבכל זאת נקדיש קצת זמן, כמה דקות לדבר על אבולוציה של Lms.
אם כן, כי סך הכל עד עכשיו דיברנו על איך הם בנויים ארכיטקטונית.
קצת דיברנו על איך עושים Influence ואיך מאמנים אותם,
אבל בעצם איך אנחנו יודעים להכריע מתי מודל שפה הוא בסדר או טוב, או מתי מודל א טוב יותר ממודל ב וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, דבר ראשון מושגים חשובים שאני יודע שלפעמים אנשים מגיעים לקורס הזה ולא מכירים אותם.
אז בכל זאת שמתי את השקף כי זה משהו מספיק חשוב לחזור עליו.
גם אם ראיתם כמה מכם שמעו על המושגים האלה Precision Recall.
איפה למדתם אותם? בהם? אוקיי, הסתדרות זה אחלה.
אז יש מישהו שיש צורך? אני יודע שבשנים קודמות פשוט היו אנשים ששאלו אותי אוקיי, אחלה, אבל מה זה ריקול?
אז כן, זה צריך לחזור אחורה. למדו את הלקח, למדו את הלקח ולמדו.
אוקיי, אחלה. יופי. אז עכשיו יש לכם רפרנס? למה זה Precision ו recall?
שתוכלו תמיד לחזור אליו. Score גם זה משהו שאין הגדירו לכם.
אז score זה פשוט ההרמוני mean. כן, ואתם מכירים את זה. זה בגדול איזשהו מדד המשקלל Precision ו recall כי קל להגדיל אחד על חשבון השני.
ואף score הוא יותר קרוב למינימום של שניהם מאשר למקסימום.
אוקיי, אז סך הכל נותן לך תמריץ לאזן אותם פחות או יותר יפה.
אחרי ההקדמה הזאת, איך אנחנו עושים אבולוציה למודל שפה?
אז התשובה הבסיסית היא אף אחד לא יודע. אוקיי, אז בואו נתחיל מהגילוי הזה.
אז אין באמת דרכים טובות לעשות אבולוציה למודל עי שפה השיטות שכן אנשים משתמשים בהן.
זה בדרך כלל שיטות שיותר מתמקדות ב Precision מאשר ב recall.
אוקיי, מה הכוונה? יותר מתמקדות בזה. יותר מתמקדות בזה שבעצם ה output שהמודל נותן הוא output מתקבל על הדעת ולא ופחות או כמעט בכלל לא.
על השאלה האם כל האאוטפיטים מתקבלים על הדעת.
המודל יכול לזהות אותם ככאלה או לפלוט אותם.
תשימו לב שהרבה למעשה זה כל כך נפוץ שאני חושב שהרבה אנשים אפילו לא מצפים ממודל השפה באמת לעשות את זה.
זאת אומרת נכון, נותנים לו איזשהו Instruction נכון?
איזשהו Instruction או איזשהו Prompt? אולי זה פישוט משהו כזה? רואים את התוצאה ומנסים להעריך עד כמה עודפות זה טוב עבור הבעיה שנתקלו בה.
אבל ככלל, בהרבה מאוד מקרים של שפה, בטח אם זו בעיה שהיא לא פרודוקציה, לא ממש גירוד של טקסט כמו תקצור או פישוט או תרגום או כתיבה של סיפור או וואטאבר.
כתיבה של מערך שיעור. יש הרבה דרכים טובות נכון לענות על שאלה תכתוב מערך שיעור על הנחיתה על הירח בעבור ילדים בכיתה א.
כן, מודלי שפה לרוב לא עושים להם ולידציה בצורה הזאת.
למה יש כאלה שטוענים כי Precision זה בעצם הרבה יותר חשוב מרמקול.
אני לא בטוח בזה. זה תלוי הקשר. בהחלט יש קשרים שזה כן, לא בכולם.
אבל לדעתי הסיבה הקשה העמוקה יותר היא שבעצם זה מאוד קשה לעשות למדוד Record.
כן, מאוד קשה למדוד Record בכל הרמות. א. מאוד קשה למדוד Recall כי צריך.
באופן עקרוני ה output space הוא עצום. אם אנחנו רוצים לייצר פישוט אז באופן עקרוני כל משפט נגיד באורך נתון בהנחת חסמים.
אותנו באורך הוא פישוט אפשרי לטקסט נתון, חלקם גרועים מאוד, חלקם פחות, אבל.
באופן עקרוני זה מאוד קשה. Even to write את כל את כל האופציות שבכלל שווה לשקול אותן.
כן, בתור נגיד קישוטים או תרגומים אפשריים, אבל זה לא רק ברמת האאוטפיטים, זה גם ברמת המשימות.
כן, גם שם יש מין Precision Recall. יש מין דגש על Precision לעומת Recall.
בדרך כלל מכריזים על כמה משימות או על כמה data סטים.
כל המשימות המרכזיות שעליהם עובדים אותם באמת בודקים את ה output שלהם טוב יותר, טוב פחות, אבל פחות או יותר.
יש לנו תמונה על כמה טובים במשימות האלה שהגדירו, אבל יש עוד הרבה משימות אחרות.
כן, אתם מבינים, עצם זה שהגדרנו מודל שפה כמשהו שיכול לענות על כל משימה שפתית, נכון?
אם תנסו אותה כמו שצריך בעצם הופכת ביתר וולידציה לבלתי אפשרית.
כן, כי כן הבנת מה הדרך בכלל לעבור על זה.
וכמובן זה קשה גם לבני אדם. זאת אומרת, אפילו אם תיקחו, נגיד, מתרגם מומחה מומחית מעולה, מתרגמת בחסד על אוקיי,
אז עכשיו לא תבקשו ממנה לתרגם את הטקסט הנתון הזה, אלא לכתוב את כל התרגומים האפשריים של המשפט הנתון לשפה נתונה.
כן, מאוד מאוד קשה, אם לא בלתי אפשרי. בסדר, אז בקיצור, זאת בעיה קשה.
Precision היא בעיה יותר פשוטה, כי סך הכל יותר קל לנו לקחת את כך וכך האאוטפיטים של המודל ואיכשהו לבדוק אותם, איך בודקים אותם, איך בודקים אותם.
אז זאת גם שאלה. כמובן שאפשר להשתמש בבני אדם, אבל מכיוון שהמודלים האלה הם כל כך מסיביים מבחינת סט המשימות שהם מסוגלים לפתור,
בדרך כלל צריך די הרבה כסף להשקיע כדי לעשות מוטציה אנושית לכל האאוטפיטים שלהם.
עושים את זה בגן אנגלי בחסכנות. אז מעדיפים דברים אוטומטיים.
מה אפשר? אבל, אבל. אוקיי, אבל איך עושים אבולוציה אוטומטית לטקסט Generation?
גם זה מסובך. למה זה מסובך? כי יש כמה דוגמאות.
יש כמה תשובות נכונות, לא? גם אם נתנו לבן אדם לפתור את זה, לא בטוח שהמכונה תפתור את זה באותה דרך.
אולי בכל זאת הדרך של המכונה לכתוב את זה היא בסדר?
אולי הדרך שהמכונה לפתור את זה הייתה פרפראזה של הדרך שחשבנו עליה לפתור את זה, וכל מה שצריך זה לזהות שיש פרפראזה.
איך פותרים את הדברים האלה? אז בגדול, יש בגדול השיטה היא אחת מכמה דרכים.
כן, שוב לא. טוען לא מושלם. רחוק מזה.
זו הייתה ההערה הראשונה שלי.
בעיה פתוחה, אבל בכל זאת, במסגרת הבעיה הפתוחה הזאת, הנה כמה common practices common practice אחד זה multiple choice customs.
multiple choice customs מראש, נכון? הנחת שווי שוק.
מי שכתב את זה עשה עבודה טובה. מראש זה כתוב ככה כך שתהיה רק תשובה אחת נכונה, נכון?
אז יש רק כך וכך אפשרויות. רק אחת מהן היא נכונה. קל מאוד לבדוק את זה אוטומטית.
אז זאת אפשרות אחת, אבל כמובן שהיא מוגבלת.
כן, כי היא מוגבלת במידה שבה הצלחנו לבנות The Structures מספיק טובים.
כן, עשיתם מספיק טובים. צורה אחרת לעשות את זה זה בעצם לבנות מין אוסף.
כן, זה לפעמים הולך גם יחד עם אולי טיפולי Choice כן, אבל לבנות איזשהו אוסף כן של משימות,
לקחת כל מיני סינרגיות שונים, כל מיני משימות שונות מן הגורן ומן היקב,
כל מיני דברים שונים ומשונים לעשות לקחת את כולם איכשהו לכל אחד מהם להסתכל על כמה מודלים שונים כן כמה מודלים מתחרים ופשוט לראות בכמה מהמקרים.
בדרך כלל לוקחים את זה מול איזשהו Pivot. כן, זאת אומרת, אומרים הנה אתה המודל הסטנדרטי.
אוקיי, אתה המודל שאנחנו קובעים את התוצאות של כולם מולך.
ועכשיו כל אחד מהם פשוט נחשב לו. Win rats לעומתו.
כן, כלומר בכמה מהמקרים users נגיד העדיפו את GPT 4 על GPT 4 טורבו או על המירה X V3 או וואטאבר.
אוקיי. ומכיוון שלפעמים אנשים גם שמחים לעשות את זה.
לא יודע אם יצא לכם. הסתכלתם על אתרים כמו מכירים אתרים כמו אלם סיס שפעם קראו לו צ'אטבוט ארינה.
כן, אז הם עובדים? כן, אז הם עובדים על מין רעיון כזה שבני אדם הרבה פעמים די שמחים לספק את חוות דעתם לגבי א טוב יותר מב.
בחינם. כן. ואז פשוט אפשר להציק להם כל הזמן להציג להם תותים וכן ולנסות.
אפשר להפוך את זה גם למשהו משחקי. כן, אפשר לבנות מזה כל מיני דברים כדי לשכנע אנשים לעשות את העבודה הזאת ואז, אבל תשימו לב שגם זה מוגבל.
נכון, זה מוגבל בכמה א. זה מוגבל על ידי אוסף המשימות שהכנסנו אליו ב.
זה מוגבל על ידי זה שיש מלא Innovations שאנחנו לא בדיוק יודעים מי הם ומה הם, ואיכשהו צריכים להתגבר על כמות גדולה של רעש.
דבר שלישי שזה בעיה זה שזה רק השוואות. נכון, אין לנו כאן שום תוצאה אבסולוטית.
אנחנו רק יודעים שמודל GPT 4 ב 96 אחוז מהמקרים הוא יותר טוב מ pivot model שאליו משווים, ולעומת זאת GPT 4 טורבו הוא טוב רק ב 84.
2. אוקיי, מעבר לזה שזה יחסי. זה גם לא בהכרח מתנהג כמו שהיינו רוצים שזה יתנהג.
כן, זה שג'יי 4 הוא יותר טוב ב 96 אחוז מהמקרים.
Reference ו GPT 4 טורבו טוב רק ב 84 נקודות, 2 אחוז Reference לא אומר שאם נשווה את GPT 4 מול GPT 4 טורבו ישירות שעדיין GPT 4 טורבו,
יותר מ 50 אחוז מהמקרים יהיה שעדיין GPT לא טורבו יהיה יותר מ 50 אחוז מהמקרים מועדף על GPT טורבו.
בקיצור יצא complete mass אבל אפשר גם את זה לעשות ואנשים עושים את זה.
זה אפילו שיטה די פופולרית ושיטה השלישית שכתבתי כאן זה באמת Prompt the models for gadgets.
כן, אומרים אוקיי, אבולוציה של Element זאת בעיה קשה, אבל יש לנו וורק Force שיודע לעשות בשבילנו כל מיני דברים.
קוראים להם Element. אז בואו ניתן לאלה למי לשפוט אלה להם עם אחרים או את אותם אלמנטים או לעשות כל מיני דברים כאלה.
וכפי שאתם מבינים זה גם שיטה עם בעיות. יש כאן כל מיני מעגליות והטיות וזה בסדר.
אם כן, אז אולי באמת אני רואה שכבר 45 אז יש לי עוד כמה מילים ככה לסיים את הדיון אחרי ההפסקה ואז נתחיל לדבר על פוסט ריק.
אגב, אני גם אצא טיפה יותר מוקדם היום, אז נסיים.
נראה לי איזה עשר דקות רבע שעה לפני שזה פגישת הערצה.
היי. כן, יש גם קצת צבע על, אבל לא הציור של המים והם הציגו את שיתוף הפעולה שלהם מצד אחד אל ה.
הנה לצורך העניין היכרות עם ארצות הברית של אמריקה צריך.
מודל מסוים. אז איך זה נראה לך? ואז?
אתה מציע? יש לנו הצעה. אז הרעיון שלכם הוא משהו מהסוג הזה?
שיש לך מניפסט ואתה יודע מה הוא עושה? אני לא יודע להסביר, אבל ברור שיש סיבות טובות יותר מאחרות.
ובכלל, אם זה לא היה יפה גם אם לא היה ממש מעניין, אבל.
בהחלט אפשר גם אחרת. טוב. אני מאוד רוצה.
לקבל את עצמי כמו שאני רוצה לתת לך איך שאתה רוצה לבדוק מה מקור השם שלך.
זה עובד ככה המשכורת שלכם? אני משווה את זה.
אז. זה?
באמת על השולחן שלי עכשיו עם כל הסכום. כי לפני הבחירות לחץ כאן הוא ממש טוב.
אתה יודע, היית צריכה להיות מפורסמת יחסית. אז כן, יש.
בזה משהו יפה. ספר לי איפה אתה אומר שזה בעייתי אבל עדיין יש כסף.
מה שזה לא יהיה, אפשר לעשות את זה שאתה לא יכול לקרוא את הספר שלך אם אתה לוקח אותו כאילו כל העבודה שלך.
אני מסכים איתך, אבל אני מצטער שאני לא משהו אחר בצהוב.
אני לא מבין כלום, אני רק לא יכול לשתוק.
אין לו מה לעשות עם החברה כל כך טוב.
אני באמת רוצה, אבל פוסטר לא משתף פעולה עם הלב של הפצוע.
אל תדאג, אתה לא שייך להיסטוריה של המאבק עכשיו.
אני מריץ את זה על החוקים והתקנות. אני רואה שמותר לך מעתה והלאה.
אני יודע. שזה לא יעזור לי.
יש פה הרבה מאוד. יש אנשים מבוגרים שכבר יש לא מעט עסקים, מעכבים משהו שגם אצלי, כנראה מתי שאתה לא לומד.
אז אחרי 250 קמ פתאום אני כבר לא יודע מה זה היה.
אני רק רוצה להגיד, אבל אתם יודעים מה זה.
זה היה תלוי במזל שלכם. אם יש לך, אולי צריך לראות איך זה מסתדר עם המחשב.
לא, לא, זה מחובר לחיבור. צריך לסיים קשר.
זה עדיין. לא בשבילי.
זה יהיה טוב. יש מחיר מבוקש על ידי חברות הסלולר בשביל התוצאות.
מה שאני לא רוצה שזה לא בשבילי.
יש לנו רעיון עסקי. אני מקווה.
שהצלחתי. לעשות כל מה שאני רוצה לעשות בשביל להבין איך אתה עושה את מה שאתה מסוגל להריץ את זה.
נכון שזה הכל גודל של העסק שלי?
סליחה על הגודל של הכרטיס הזה. בנוסף, הוא גם לא נראה כאילו אני כבר שלוש שנים.
אז מה דעתך על הפוסט שלי? אני רואה את זה כאילו זה מומלץ וזה כל כך טוב.
למה אתה צריך להמתין לביקור בארץ? אין בעיה. אין תגובות. איך אתה עושה את זה?
יש סיכוי שאני צריך פונקציות כמו שצריך?
אין. לי שום בעיה עם זה.
קודם כל לא. יש גם 2 תוצאות חיפוש. אני חושבת שזה לוקח.
הרבה זמן. מה עושים לדבר איתך על זה?
זה מעשה שנעשה. זה לא שהוא לא בסדר, אבל לא ברור לי שהיא עוברת.
אתה מתפלא? אולי זה עדיין לא, אבל אם אתה עושה את זה.
אני לא מבין מה זה אומר. כי אחרי סוף זה משהו בסגנון.
אתה צודק, אבל זה גם משהו בצוואר. מה זה?
איפה זה של כוחות החיפוש ביחידה? בוא, בוא נגיד ככה.
תלוי בזה אף אחד. אתה לא רוצה אותו ואין לך הרבה אופי.
לא יודעת עד כמה. מה שאני אומר זה מה שאני באמת שם איתך.
אבל בהתחשב בזה כל הזמן שלך זה לא עבר עד היום.
זה נראה מפחיד, נכון? בשלב זה לא ברור מה זה עושה, אבל זה לא כאילו זה לא נראה כאילו הוא חשב על העתיד.
בעיקרון כשאתה מבין לא עושים את זה. לפעמים אתה נכנס לשם.
הנשמה דעת יוצר בעצם. לחץ להמשך? כאבי בטן?
רוצה לחוות דעת נוספת. מסוימת שמשקפת את הדופק בצורה עיוורת.
זה יכול להיות אבל זה נועד. 1. 2.
עכשיו אני עושה. רושם חיובי גם אם אתה לא משהו של הפונקציה הזאת.
יאללה. זה התיאור של הפטריות. 3.
זה כאילו. גם כן עושים לך את הטסט.
לא סתם סיסמה אבל גם זה היה מגיע כדי לקבל.
ציון נמוך. שבו הרבה אנשים לא עושים כלום.
זה בדיוק מה שצריך לעשות.
זה פשוט עטיפה של חלק מהמוצרים באופן מלא של וילסון, אבל זה לא מספיק, והמרצה מתייחס לזה שאני לא יכול לשמוע את המשטרה וזה גם אחרי שכל זה נראה כרגע?
מבחינה מסויימת אפשר לא יהיה בזה. יש לך?
לא כאילו הבעיות האלה לא היה צריך לקרות, אבל אני יודע שאנשים לא הכי טובים בתור מתחילים להרגיש שלוקחים את הסיפור הזה.
ברכות ואיחולים. זה לא הזמן לספר מה אתה עושה פה כבר מזמן, אבל זה טוב, אתה לא עושה את מה את רוצה לעשות, זה כבר לא מגיע לו.
איך אתה עושה לו? איך אתה עושה את זה? ליווי בנקאי מה לעשות?
תן לו את כל הטקסטים של האינטרנט שלו עכשיו.
אני חושב שאתה בן 14. טקסטים? לא כל טקסטים מורכבים בנושאים האלה.
כן, אני חושב שזה בסדר היום השני. של שישי זה ממש ממש לא שלי.
לא, אני לא יודע. לא הייתי עושה מה שאני לא.
עושה את זה. ממליצה לך לעשות את השינוי הזה. זה פשוט לא מספיק שלך.
קח את הזמן, אתה יכול לעשות כל דבר שאני אעשה את זה.
זה לא מה שאתה עושה. זה בדיוק. זה אומר שגם הם עושים את זה?
אני לא אני, אבל אני עושה. את זה בעצם ככה.
הוא סבור שזה קצת בעייתי.
יכול להיות שאתה חושב את זה סוציולוגי? בוא נעשה את זה בצורה כזאת ואז בסוף.
אני לא רוצה להגיע למצב שאתה לא רוצה להגיע.
כנראה שלא הייתי ממליץ לעשות את זה.
זה אומר שאנחנו עושים היסטוריה? רוצה לעבוד עם פסיכולוג?
אפשר למצוא סוגים של עושה. את זה בסדר.
שישה טיפים אין שום סיבה שלא. תרצה לעשות את זה?
חלק שני. ואז תראה. זה.
לא העניין שלי בכל העולם לפני שאני עושה את זה, תלוי בה כל השנה.
אני לצערי לא פשוט יוצא מזה כאשר אני לא מצליח להשיג את המטרה שלי.
אני מגיע ליעד ואנחנו רוצים להגיע אליו כאילו אין כמו מקודם על הטבע שלנו.
יש להם כובע. קסקט ולא לגמרי יש לי.
אבל על זה יש לי חדשות. מאז לא הבנתי את זה.
זה היה יכול להיות שזה לא היה מספיק דפוק.
כיוון שהיה לי כפי שאני רוצה לעשות.
זה לא. היה.
זה לא היה איזה שינוי דורה. כאילו.
תדמיין כאילו ואני כבר מבין שיש לך עכשיו. לא יודע מה זו תמונה מושלמת ועכשיו אני בכל זאת רוצה.
נניח פה את הסיפור הזה של בן אדם ואז פה יש לו את זה שהיה כאן בתמונה.
אחרי זה עצמו ידעתי אז עושים את כל מה שאתה.
אתה רוצה ילדים כאילו אתה אתה, משהו שמראה שיש לך חלק באופנוע שעכשיו הוא היום וחלק מסוימות כאילו אתה רואה שהצינור גז.
בניוטרל של הבלוג היא זאת שעושה את זה.
הרי לא קולטים את זה בדיוק עכשיו אני דיברתי עם כמה וכמה פעמים.
גם אתה אומר את זה בכל זאת עושה משהו שאתה לא מכיר.
הבינו. את עצמי נשמע לי מוזר.
ככה זה. כמה זמן נמשך אותו תפקוד קוגניטיבי התנהגותי?
אצלי שתיקה מביכה. מטרת האימון. האימון אמור לייצר 36 שעות, אבל הרעיון לא יכול לבוא עם.
ציפיות גבוהות. תראה, אם יש יותר זמן יש שיפור כל שנייה.
אני לא מבין איך אתה עושה את.
זה? אני גם אם אתה אומר. רגע, רק מנסה להרגיש טוב.
אני לא חש אשמה. אז איך זה? זה ממש לא קשה.
זה בסדר בסופו של דבר. האם טכנית התיאורים של החיים לא מתאימים?
היסטוריה? זה לא שאני לא יכול. לא.
לא. כן. לא לדאוג גם אם זה לא מסוכן.
אבל הבנתי את זה. לא חשבתי על זה.
אני לא יודע. אם צריך לעזור להפחית את צריכת החשמל?
כן. נחמד. אני מניחה שזה בגלל שהוא סגור.
כאילו איך נעשה את זה? אני לא יודעת אם זה לא איזה יופי.
זה לא קשור לזה.
כאילו כל פעם מנסה להחזיר לי את המילה בעמ 39. ברור.
זה לא עניין של מה לא בסדר. ממש מבחינה תעסוקתית הילד עובד תזמורת בבאר שבע, אבל זה לא.
זה לא מספיק. זה כמו שאני אוהבת את זה. זאת אומרת, לא מחמיאה?
הוא כזה. הוא לא מעניין. אותי.
אני מסתכל על הטקסט, על כל מיני דברים שמעניינים אותי.
זה אותו דבר. ההבדלים שלא היו מבוססים על הסקאלה, שמצאו אותי עם הרבה יותר מזה.
ממש לא. לא כזה נורא, לא עושה את העבודה.
עכשיו אנחנו נדבר קצת על מה ההבדל בין זה לבין מספר שתיים?
לא, אבל זה פחות משלוש שנים. אז מה?
אז איך זה? אני לא יודע. אני. לא מאשים ולא עשיתי את זה.
כמה פשוט, ככה אני מעריץ את. התהליך הזה.
אני חייב לומר אני חושב שזה לא. זה לא יכול להתגבר על זה, אבל עכשיו אתה לא צריך לעשות זאת.
יש מצב רוח? טוב.
אז. זה מה שקורה בשטח.
אוקיי, נמשיך. זה?
בסדר. אז סיימנו את השיעור הקודם בעצם בדיון על Elevation ספציפית אמרנו, דיברנו קצת על הקשיים ודיברתי על זה שבגלל הצורך באוטומציה Evaluation.
בעצם יש כמה שיטות שמשתמשים בהן. בכל זאת, אחת מהן זה Multiple choice.
כן, שאולי קשה לכתוב, אבל קל לבדוק אז אפשרות אחת.
אפשרות שנייה שדיברנו עליה. אפשרות שנייה שדיברנו עליה זה בעצם להשתמש בכל מיני Framework ים, שבעצם כוללים בדרך כלל כוללים כל מיני משימות,
אבל לעשות מה שנקרא Crowd sourcing של crowd sourcing שלהן רוטציה במקום לקחת מתרגמים או אנשים מיומנים,
פשוט לתת להמונים לתייג ולעשות איזושהי אגרגציה על סמך התוצאות שלהם.
בדרך כלל בהשוואה יחסית כן, כי אין כל כך משמעות.
מה הציון שאתם נותנים לסיכום הבא? כי אני מאוד קשה להבין בכלל מה זה אומר.
זו השוואה לרוב יחסית. פרדיגמה השלישית זה.
הזכרתי אותה במילה ועכשיו אני אגיד עליה עוד כמה מילים בודדות.
זה בעצם פרדיגמה של לתת ל language models להעריך את עצמם באיזשהו מובן.
מה שקוראים לפעמים Lms כן, זה השם המקובל או language models גאדג.
אוקיי, אז Lms. בקיצור, המתודולוגיה פחות או יותר הולכת ככה.
כן? אז כן, המתודולוגיה הולכת ככה אנחנו לוקחים איזשהו מודל.
בדרך כלל המודל הכי חזק שעליו אנחנו יכולים לשים את הידיים.
כן, בשאיפה שיהיה יותר חזק משמעותית מאשר המודל שייצר.
כן, כי כי אחרת בעצם מה שאנחנו עושים זה באיזשהו מובן פשוט מאמנים את המודל עם המודל שעושים לו אבולוציה או יותר חזק מהמודל של שופט.
אז יכול להיות שמה שיקרה כנראה מה שיקרה זה שהמודל החזק יותר פשוט ידע להתאים את עצמו לפרדיגמה של המודל החלש יותר ששופט אותו,
אבל ההפך אולי יהיה לו קשה כי הוא מודל יותר קטן, יותר חלש, אז אולי יש לזה יותר תוקף.
סליחה? ובגדול אנחנו נראה כמה וריאנטים שונים.
כן, משום מה כתבתי טור אבל התכוונתי ל free three main variant.
אוקיי, האחד מהם זה מה שנקרא pair ווייז, שזה בעצם מאוד דומה למוטציה אנושית שאמרנו, רק שעכשיו מודל שפה מבצע את זה.
יש לנו Prompt. כן או כן איזשהו אינפוט למודל What does today today.
נגיד, ולמשל בוא נגיד שהמודל של open ai הנה How do I know והמודל של אנטרופי.
Today Tuesday it שוער. ואז שאלנו את ה Lms גאדג וה Lms גאדג אמר נגיד שהתשובה של אנטרופי היא יותר טובה.
לדוגמה. אוקיי, אז זה הפר ווייז כי הוא משווה. הסינגל Output.
זה בעצם רעיון דומה, רק שאנחנו מגדירים לו סקאלה של תוצאות.
אוקיי, אז עכשיו הוא עובד על Output של מודל אחד. נגיד למשל, הוא אומר שהנה סקאלה בין 1 ל 10 כשאחד זה כמה שזה הכי זה 10, זה הכי טוב ואחד זה הכי גרוע.
אז אולי נגיד הוא יפלוט 10 להוא דיינו. אולי זה מין יוזר שמעריך אחד שמעריך.
Bad attitude כזה? מי יודע? כן. ויש את בעצם את הווריאנט של multiple output שהוא די דומה לסינגל output.
ההבדל בו זה שבעצם יש לי כמה מימדים שונים שאליהם אני עושה אבולוציה.
אוקיי, ובדרך כלל גם המימדים האלה הם on this close.
כן, הם לא נתונים ל model שמייצר.
אוקיי, אז מה הכוונה? אתם צריכים? תחשבו על זה כמו שאתם צריכים.
לא יודע מה להגיש עבודה במשפטים. הבנתי. זה הרבה פעמים עובד ככה.
יש גם תלמידי משפטים במקרה. אוקיי, אז אני שמעתי שהרבה פעמים תרגילים במשפטים עובדים ככה.
יש איזשהו מחוון כזה? כן, שאומר הוא היה צריך להזכיר את הפסק דין הזה וזה האם הוא הזכיר אותו?
הוא היה צריך להגיד שזה מתייחס לפרדיגמה השיפוטית על שם מישהו?
כן וכן הלאה וכן הלאה. אוקיי, כל אחד מהם יש. אולי זה בינארי, אולי זה ציון, לא משנה מה יש קריטריונים.
מטבע הדברים אתם לא נותנים לסטודנטים את הקריטריונים כי זה היה הופך את כל התרגיל.
קצת מטופש, אבל כל אחד מהקריטריונים האלה אולי עדיין דורש איזשהו שיפוט אנושי.
כן, זה לא משהו כזה של למצוא מילה. בסדר, זה פשוט אפשר להריץ סקריפט נכון ולא צריך פה שום דבר מיוחד.
לא צריך language models, אבל הרבה מהדברים נכון הם קצת יותר זה האם להשתמש במשלב ראוי.
אוקיי, נכון, זה משהו שצריך language models או משהו?
כן לא. לא מספיק פשוט איזשהו regular expressions. אז בעצם הרעיון כאן זה שאיכשהו מה שיש לנו זה איזשהו מודל שהגג מודל הזה.
מה שהוא מקבל זה את ה output. אוקיי, הוא מקבל לפעמים גם reference.
אוקיי, כלומר הוא מקבל לפעמים גם כן פתרון אנושי.
לא תמיד, אבל משהו להשוות אליו.
אוקיי, אבל הוא לא משווה אחד לאחד כמו בבלוז Score לא משווה בין גרמים, אלא משווה לפי אוסף קריטריונים שבאיזשהו Rating ביניהם,
שנקבע בצורה אדפטיבית לשאלה, כלומר שנקבע על בסיס הנתונים הספציפיים של השאלה הנוכחית.
אוקיי, אז זה מין סוג של Language, מודל יותר מתוחכם שבכל זאת מסתיר חלק מהמידע, אבל עדיין עושה את זה בצורה כזאת שבעצם זה יהיה המוטציה.
תהיה עבורי Russell. כן, כי אם תחשבו על זה, אם לקחתם את נגיד Innovations פה ואמרתם להם האם מודל סליחה פה?
האם מודל א? האם מודל א טוב יותר?
האם ציפיתי 4 יותר טוב משציפיתי 4 טורבו עבור הדוגמא הזאת? זה לא Highly Reasonable זה Single זה חד פעמי.
נכון? כאילו עבור זוג האאוטפיטים הזה מה התוצאה? שיניתם את אאוטפיטים?
עכשיו צריך לשאול עוד פעם אותם? או language model או לא משנה מה צריך.
אבל אם אתם אם מה שאתם עושים זה מגדירים קריטריונים,
אז אפילו אם זה לקח לכם יחסית הרבה עבודה להגדיר מה בדיוק ה waiting צריך להיות בין הקריטריונים במחווה נכון ומה הם בדיוק צריכים להיות.
זה עדיין משהו שאתם עכשיו יכולים להשתמש בו על הרבה אאוטפיטים שונים.
אוקיי, אז זה נראה כמו אולי ניצול טוב יותר של העבודה האנושית בלכתוב קריטריונים.
למרות שאני צריך להגיד לכם שגם שם הרבה פעמים מפעילים language models כדי שיצרו את הקריטריונים, כך שהכל הפך קצת כאוטי.
בסדר. טוב.
דבר נוסף שאני רציתי להגיד כאיזשהו הערה זה שאפשר גם ללכת ולקחת את ה ולהשתמש בעצם ב models אבל לא לקחת אותם עד הסוף.
שנשתמש ב language models change, אלא לעשות משהו קצת יותר באמצע.
אז מה הכוונה נגיד למשל? יכול להיות שמה שאני רוצה לפתור זה איזה שהיא משימה של ייצור טקסט?
אוקיי, נגיד למשל, שלדעת מה מזג האוויר? אוקיי, מה מזג האוויר היום?
אני יודע, סן פרנסיסקו אוקיי, אז. ועכשיו יש לי נגיד Reference שאותו כתב בן אדם שאני סומך עליו, כמו נגיד The Weather is called Today.
אוקיי, ויש לי את ה output של המכונה. It is free today.
בסדר, אז עכשיו מה שאני יכול אז קיצון אחד זה לעשות משהו כמו blue score.
נכון פשוט לראות כמה חפיפה יש לי בין גרמים, אבל לזה יש בעיה כמובן, כי אם לא השתמשתי בדיוק באותן המילים לא אקבל ציון נמוך.
אני יכול לקחת כל הדרך language models gauge. כן, אבל אז אני לא כל כך אדע למה הוא חשב שזה דומה.
חמש ולא דומה שבע או דומה שבע ולא דומה ארבע וכן הלאה.
כן, זה לגמרי או פייק לגמרי. אני לא יודע להסביר את התוצאה.
אני יכול ללכת לאיזושהי דרך ביניים שהיא אומרת אוקיי, אני אשווה את עצמי ל רפרנס.
כן, אבל אני אעשה את זה בצורה שאני פחות או יותר מבין אותה. מהי למשל כיוון אחד זה מאמר כאן זה נקרא Bird score.
זה אומר אני אייצר לכל שאלה לכל סיכה.
מילה ב output בקנדידה ב output של המכונה ולכל מילה ב reference.
אייצר bird עם Padding אייצר קונטקסט. Wedding Padding.
אני עכשיו אסתכל על המטריצה דמיון שלהם.
אוקיי, אני אסתכל על מטריצת דמיון של בין המילים.
אוקיי, ואני אגיד קנדידה טוב זה קנדידה שבו אני יכול למצוא התאמה.
כן, אני יכול בעצם כל מילה ב Reference למפות אותה למילה בקנדידה סט.
ככה ש. שהדמיון הממוצע ביניהם יהיה די גבוה לפי איזשהו סף שקבעתי.
או משהו בסגנון הזה? אוקיי, אז זה איזושהי דרך שהיא היא דרך ביניים, נכון?
כי היא לא כל הדרך הג'אז שבה אני מקבל פשוט תוצאה ואני צריך כאילו לעשות כן לקחת אותה או לא לקחת אותה.
אני כל כך שום ידע מה קרה שם, איפה זה נכשל? למה הוא חושב שזה גרוע או טוב?
כאן יש לי קצת יותר אינטרנט טבליות כי אני אומר אוקיי, זה גרוע, כי המילה השלישית לגמרי התבקשה.
אין לה אף מילה שמתאימה לה. אוקיי, אז זה משהו שהוא.
מצד שני, הבריטים Weddings עצמם הם משהו ארופאי.
כשאני לא יודע בדיוק איך לפרט, יכול להיות שהוא נתן פרטים Padding שאני לא מסכים איתו, או שהוא לא נכון, או שהוא קרוב מדי או רחוק מדי מילימטר.
אוקיי, אז בקיצור, בגלל זה אני קורא לזה איזושהי דרך ביניים. שאלות.
אוקיי, אז אם נסכם את הפרק הזה על פרי טריינינג, אז פרי טריינינג הוא בעצם היה כן.
Game Changer קוראים לזה לפעמים ממש עושה איזשהו Party Time Shift בnlp בשנים האחרונות בעצם כבר מתקרב לעשור 9 8 שנים אחרונות.
בעצם זה התחיל בקונטקסט של Alias וורדים, Bad Things שדיברנו עליהם ועל היתרון שלהם לעומת לעומת Non קונטקסט עם Bad Things.
אחרי זה בעצם זה עבר יותר.
הפוקוס עבר בעצם לזירה שוט ופיוס שוט, ופה הפאזה האחרונה זה בדיוק הפאזה.
שנדבר עליה עכשיו שזה הנושא של אינטרנט Models. אוקיי, אז זה ככה.
סיכום קצר וזה מוביל אותנו ישירות לנושא שלנו היום שזה אינטרנט models ופוסטרים.
אוקיי, טוב, אז בעצם אם Struct Models הם באיזשהו מובן משנים או לא, באיזשהו מובן הם משנים בצורה מאוד מהותית את ההגדרה של מה זה מודל שפה.
אוקיי, אז אנחנו דיברנו על מודל שפה בימי השיעור השני של הקורס.
אני חושב, אולי הראשון, נכון. ואיך הגדרנו מודל שפה? בלבד כדי שנצליח?
כן, בדיוק מודל שנותן התפלגות על פני המילה הבאה, או באופן שקול מודל הסתברותי שנותן הסתברויות למחוזות סופיות.
כן למשפטים, לטקסטים וכן הלאה. ואז אמר ואז דרך הבסיסית להשתמש בו נכון היא בהינתן איזה שהוא רישא או בהינתן משפט שלם.
כן, נגיד, בהינתן רישא לדעת מה המילה הבאה, או בהינתן משפט כמה משפטים שלמים להגיד, לאיזה מהם יש הסתברות גבוהה יותר מהשני.
כן, שימושים מהסוג הזה. אבל בעצם החל מהמודלים האלה בהתחלה לא היו מאוד טובים בלייצר טקסט.
הם היו טובים לדברים אחרים, אבל בעצם החל מ GPT 2 ובוודאי GPT 3 הם כבר הפכו להיות מודלים שמסוגלים לייצר טקסט בצורה מרשימה.
מה שכאילו גרם בו נאמר לתחום להפוך להיות יותר ויותר שאפתני ובעצם להגיד מה שאני רוצה בעצם ממודל השפה.
זה לא פשוט שישלים מטקסטים, אלא הייתי רוצה שהוא יהיה גם בעצם מסוגל להיות מודל אוניברסלי שעובר אדפטציה לצרכים הספציפיים שלי על בסיס הנחיות שאני נותן לו.
כן, אם סך הכל זה מודל שמבין שפה טבעית, אז למה שגם שהממשק אליו לא יהיה פשוט על ידי הוראות בשפה טבעית?
למה אני צריך ללכת ולמצוא דוגמאות ולעשות פיו שוט Learning?
או לעשות או לעשות fine tuning או להנדס את ה Prompt ככה שזה יהיה לי איי קיו איי ולבנות את זה נכון?
כך שהוא יידע למה לי להתעסק בכל הבוץ הרס הזה?
כן, יש לי פה מערכת אוטומטית. כן, המערכת הזאת היא מערכת שמבוססת על שפה טבעית.
בוא נדבר אליה כמו בשפה טבעית. אוקיי, וכן, נתתי פה דוגמה.
נגיד למשל זה משהו שניסיתי אתמול, פשוט להיות בטוח שכן שום דבר פה לא השתנה.
אז נגיד התחלתי את המשפט Most מדי European scholars believe that the earth was.
אוקיי. ואז הנה פה שני מודלים לפניכם אחד.
מודל מכובד בגודלו. כן, עם שמונה מיליארד פרמטרים של מטה.
קוראים לו למה 3, 8 B ומשהו המשיך את זה זה למשל flat and I believe that was flat because day.
או למשל המשיך את זה flat. דיסק זה by water או flat או את Center of the universe, but this belief וממשיך וכן הלאה.
אוקיי. ולעומת זאת מודלים מודלי Struct כמו שאני מניח אתם רגילים כבר לקבל אם תשאלו שאלה כזאת.
שאלתי ספציפית את עולמו שהוא מודל פתוח, אבל תקבלו משהו דומה גם אם ציפיתי או עם קלוד או עם מה שאתם אוהבים.
נכון, אני אגיד לכם משהו כזה. Most developers colours believe that the first was at the center of the universe,
there are no pain and can stars reveal around that this video is known as the go central model and was the idea of the Greek,
פילוסופיה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה. אוקיי, עכשיו כמה הבדלים כאן.
דבר ראשון, אפילו אם נכון, זאת מין בעיה שלכאורה ניסחתי את זה כבר, ככה שהוא לא פשוט שההמשך הוא יספק לי את התשובה, נכון?
בוא נגיד שרציתי לדעת מה התשובה לשאלה במה?
מה היה האמונה של קן European Developing Colours לגבי הצורה לגבי ה כן לא יודע מאפיינים של כדור הארץ, אבל אני פשוט ביקשתי ממנו להמשיך.
תשימו לב שיש פה כמה הבדלים. אז דבר ראשון המודל למה 3 1 8 B כמודל שהוא רק פרי טרייד.
הוא פשוט המשיך את זה בעוד שהמודל עולמו זה הבין או פירש את ה Prompt שלי בתור Prompt שבו אני
מבקש לשאול על ה את השאלה הזאת שכן של מאיה עמדי וליאו פיינס Scholars Believe About the earth,
ואז נתן לי מין תשובה מפורטת והסביר בטטה טה טה טה טה טה.
אבל יש פה גם עוד הבדל חשוב. אוקיי, ויש כאן עוד הבדל חשוב.
וזה שבעצם מסתבר שהתשובה שלמה בכוונה לקחתי את הדוגמה הזאת.
כן, שהתשובה של למה 3 8 B עד דוגמה או לפחות שבשלוש מחמש גנריות שעשיתי איתו.
נתן הוא פשוט לא נכונה. כן, היא עובדתית לא נכונה.
כן מסתבר. וזה כן כבר ידוע לא מעט שנים שזה לא נכון.
כן, זה בתקופת הרנסאנס, או אולי קצת אחריה?
כן, אז העלילו על עמוס מדי ולרופאים סקולר שהם האמינו שהארץ שטוחה.
למעשה, זאת הייתה דעה של מיעוט קטן בקרב אותם זה, וזה יותר ממשהו, מסתבר.
כן, יש איזה מיתוס. כן, עכשיו.
אוקיי, אז עכשיו בוא ננסה לחשוב על זה דרך הפרספקטיבה של המשימה שבמודל שפה שהוא פשוט לתת הסתברויות לדברים שאנשים עשויים להגיד,
לעומת מודל שאמור לענות על השאלה, מודל שפשוט אמור להמשיך טקסט בצורה שבדרך כלל ממשיכים אותה בסיס הקורפוס שהוא ראה זה להגיד שהוא flat או flat דיסק.
כן, זו תשובה מעולה. נכון, כי הרבה מאוד אנשים אם ישאלו אותם, כולל אני, עד שבמקרה נתקלתי בעובדה הזו לא מזמן, יגידו שזה מה שהם חשבו שהארץ היא שטוחה.
כן, אז בהחלט כמודל שפה שאמור לתת הסתברות גבוהה לדברים שאנשים סביר שיגידו הוא אחלה.
נגיד למשל, אם אתם רוצים להשתמש בזה כדי לסנן רעשים ב speech to טקסט נכון,
ואתם רוצים מודל שבאמת יחזה, מה המילה הבאה כדי לתת לכם prior למילה הבאה כדי לעשות Coding יותר טוב?
זה מעולה שהוא יגיד שזה כנראה פלט נכון כי אז הוא יידע שמשהו כבר אז הוא יידע להבין מה זה פלט נכון אם יש שם איזה רעש,
אבל כמודל שמנסה לענות על השאלה הזאת בצורה נכונה על בסיס הידע שקיים כיום זה תשובות גרועות מאוד.
נכון תשובות גרועות מאוד. אז תשימו לב וזו נקודה מאוד חשובה, כי בעצם לא רק כי עד השלב של GPT 3 או של הפרי training שדיברנו עליו.
Large language models הראשונים בעצם עדיין עסקנו באותה בעיה שהיא התעסקנו בה מהשיעור השני בקורס.
רק עכשיו עם טכנולוגיה אחרת יותר חזקה, יותר, data יותר. האינטרנט Models הם במובן הזה קו פרשת מים, כי הם לקחו עדיין את המושג הזה של Language Model.
ובאמת, באמת Under the Hood הם מאוד דומים ארכיטקטונית.
ל Language models עושים בדרך כלל בדיוק אותו דבר כמו Language Model שהכרנו לפני כן, אבל הם עכשיו עושים משהו אחר.
הם מנסים לפתור משימה אחרת שהיא קצת דומה, מספיק דומה כדי לבלבל אנשים לחשוב שזו אותה אחת, אבל בעצם הם קצת חושבים על זה.
מבינים שהיא גם שונה בצורות משמעותיות. אז הנה כמה הבדלים עיקריים.
אז דבר ראשון Instruction following is an interaction. כלומר אני צריך להבין את מה שנקרא employee intent of the user.
אוקיי, המשימה של מודל שפה ראשונית היא על פניו לא משימה אינטראקטיבית.
היא לא דורשת שני גורמים. כן, איכשהו יהיו באינטראקציה.
נכון, זה פשוט טקסט ועל בסיס הרבה מאוד טקסט.
קודם שראיתי אני צריך להגיד איך נראה ההמשך של הטקסט. כאן בעצם יש את מה שנקרא פרגמטיקה.
למי מכם שלמד קצת על בלשנות או על פילוסופיה של השפה, לא כל כך למדתם על זה ולומדים על זה.
עכשיו יש פה אתגר גדול. אוקיי, אז אחלה.
אז פרגמטיקה יש המון אספקטים. כן, אבל אם אתם מכירים כל דובר שפה מכיר את זה.
כן, לשפה יש בעצם לשפה שהיא נמצאת בקונטקסט מסוים, כמו שכל שפה תמיד נמצאת.
היא לא פשוט אוסף ענק של טקסטים שמישהו הוריד מהאינטרנט וכבר שכחנו מאיפה הורדנו ומה עשינו איתם נכון בשיחה או בכל סוג של אינטראקציה שפתית יש איזשהו הקשר,
יש את הכוונה של הדובר כפי שאני מבין אותה ויש איזושהי אינטראקציה.
ואולי אני מנסה לשאול משהו עובדתי. אולי אני מנסה לשכנע.
אולי אני מנסה לאסור על משהו? אולי אני מנסה להתחנף?
אני לא יודע. וואטאבר. יש כל מיני דברים שאנשים עושים עם השפה ויש כל מיני אינטרנט שונים, ואני איכשהו צריך להבין אותם.
אם אני משתמש בשפה בצורה אינטראקטיבית זה דבר אחד. למשל, ראינו בעיה של בדיוק מהסוג הזה סביב הנושא הזה של מון.
נו, הנושא הזה של להסביר את הנחיתה על הירח לילד בן 6, נכון?
אם אני לא מבין Employee Intent הוא תספר לי כאילו תכתוב לי סיפור, תכתוב לי הסבר.
אז אני יכול לפלוט דברים שהם לגמרי בסדר כהמשך של הטקסט, אבל הם לא מתאימים ל Intent כפי שרוב הקוראים יבינו אותו.
הם פשוט יקראו את ההוראה. אוקיי, אז זה הבדל אחד.
הבדל שני הוא שבגלל ש Instruction מניח איזשהו Employee Intent of the user, כן, בגלל שזה כבר מערב אינטראקציה.
בדרך כלל אנחנו רוצים גם להכניס איזשהם סוגים של Safety Strings או של Guardians.
כן, זה כמובן גם מסיבות מסחריות. כן, אנחנו אולי open AI לא רצו שהאינטרנט במודל שלהם יפלוט.
אני לא יודע מה תוכן ניאו נאצי ולא יודע כל מיני דברים כאלה.
אוקיי, אבל יש כאן גם משהו שבאמת מתייחס לאופי של הבעיה.
נכון? אם עכשיו מה שאני צריך לעשות זה to end for the intent of the user.
אוקיי, אז. אז בעצם עכשיו להחזיר תוכן ניאו נאצי זה באיזשהו מובן הרבה יותר גרוע מאשר קודם.
כי קודם כל מה שעשיתי זה. ניסיתי להנדס את הפרסומת ככה שהוא יפלוט לי בתשובה את משהו שאני אוכל להבין ממנו את התשובה לשאלה שלי.
אוקיי, ושם כאילו הציפיות היו יותר נמוכות, כל מה שהוא צריך זה להשלים את הטקסט בצורה מתקבלת על הדעת,
וכאילו האחריות עלי היא לנסות לחלץ מה Output את התשובה לשאלה שרציתי.
כן, אבל אם מראש הוא מוגדר כ צ'אטבוט ולא פשוט כאותו Complete כן,
אז זה כאילו נהיה יותר חמור באיזשהו מובן, כי זה אומר שאני כן חושב שיש פה משהו אינטואיטיבי.
כן, לא רק מסחרי, כי כאילו, כי באיזשהו מובן זה אומר שאני מייחס לבן שיחי את הכוונה שמה שהוא רצה זה תוכן ניאו נאצי.
כן אה אוקיי, שזה בסדר.
זה כן זה? זה לא הרבה אינטראקציות. עכשיו יכול להיות שזה מה שהוא התכוון אגב.
ואז זה מביא אותנו לבעיה אחרת.
כן, זה שזאת בעיה באמת של ה safety constant ו guard rails שהיא בעיה שהיא באמת כן קשורה, קשורה באמת לזה שהם פשוט עכשיו פתחו את זה הרבה יותר.
עניין מסחרי. כן. שבעצם אמרו אוקיי, פתחנו את המוצר עכשיו לשימוש של הדיוטות.
בעצם, נכון, זה כבר לא. אנשים שמבינים בnlp בונים את ה Prompt בצורה מיוחדת ואז מחלצים ממנו את מה שהם רוצים.
זה עכשיו כן ציפיתי, ציפיתי, זה משהו. לא יודע שאנשים מכל הסוגים נכון?
לא כאילו. אוקיי, אז ברור שהחשיבות עולה. בסדר.
ובאמת עוד הבדל הוא של network Addiction הוא density activation problem.
אוקיי וללא בעיית דיקציה שגם זה חשוב. אוקיי, אז מה הכוונה?
זה בדיוק הדבר שעליו בעצם מתייחס הדבר שדיברנו עליו קודם?
אז אם אני מסתכל כאן על Most developed scholars believe that the art walls, נכון?
אז אמרנו זה שבוא נגיד שרוב האנשים חושבים שהיא הייתה שטוחה שהצליחה.
רוב האנשים חושבים שתלמידי פול סקולס חשבו שהיא הייתה שטוחה, אבל נגיד חמישה אחוז לא חושבים ככה.
אלה שמכירים את הנושא והתעמקות בו. אז בואו נגיד בקורפוס שלנו, העצום שעליו עשינו פרי טריינינג.
ב 5 אחוז מהמקרים כתוב שהוא היה ספיר קל וב 95 אחוז כתוב שהוא היה flat.
סתם כדי לפשט את הדוגמה. אוקיי, מה language model סוג ראשון version 1 פוינט או אמור לעשות ככה?
הכי נפוץ? לא, לא את האחד הכי נפוץ. הוא אמור לתת 95 אחוז הסתברות לפלט וחמישה אחוז.
כן, נכון, כי בואו ניזכר שנייה למדתם, למדתם על כוס אנטרופי לוס, נכון?
אז מה ממקסם את הקרוס אנטרופי? לוס מקבלת 95?
אתה בדיוק 95 על flat. זה משהו שלמדתם באימייל או שצריכים שאני אחזור על זה?
אני אחזור על זה אז בשיעור הבא נראה לי כי זה כבר מאוחר. אוקיי.
על כל פנים, הדרך הנכונה אם מה שאני רוצה זה לייצג את ההתפלגות כן של הטורקים שמגיעים, שזה בעצם מה שעשינו עד עכשיו.
אני צריך לתת 95 הסתברות לפליקס חמישה אחוז הסתברות לצביקה.
אוקיי, אבל אם אני עכשיו מודל עם Struct שאמור לשקף שהוא אמור להיות צ'אטבוט כן, שמבצע איתי אינטראקציה בשם כידע הארוך.
ידו הארוכה של open AI זה לא טוב.
אם הוא יגיד לי פלט כן זה לא טוב כי זה מוציא את העובדה היא קצת טמבלים.
נכון? אז כאילו תפקיד אחר. בסדר, אז יש כאן הבדלים מאוד משמעותיים, בסדר.
כל התחום שעוסק באיך לקחת מודל שהוא Next post production model כן, מהסוג שהכרנו ואהבנו ולהפוך אותו לאינסטינקט Model.
כל התחום הזה נקרא post training. למה הוא נקרא post training?
זה בעצם סתם כאילו. בעצם זה כאילו לא פרי טריינינג, אלא מה שבא אחר כך.
זה כאילו פוסט טריינינג, אבל פוסט טריינינג נשמע כאילו זה מה שעושים אחרי האימון.
אבל זה לא. זה פשוט. האימון זה פשוט חלק באימון. אולי אפשר היה לקרוא לזה פוסט פרי טריינינג, אולי זה היה יותר מדויק.
אז בסדר, אז זאת הכוונה. טוב, ובעצם הגישה הזאת.
כן, אני חושב שאני אגיד אותה על קצה המזלג ונסיים את הדיון בשבוע הבא.
זה בעצם הוא הולך להיות מורכב. הפוסט טריינינג הולך להיות מורכב משני שלבים.
כן, אז שוב, זה שלב שקורה אחרי הפרי טריינינג. כן, בשלב הזה כבר יש לנו ביד מודל עם פרמטרים שמסוגלים לבצע next post production בצורה מתקבלת על הדעת.
ועכשיו אני עושה בעצם שני שלבים האחד מהם קוראים לו Soft או Super Voice Fine Tuning והשני הוא
נקרא re learning ספציפית שימוש ב policy Gradient method שזה תת סוג של learning method.
אז עכשיו שאלתי היא כזאת מי כאן נתקל במושג Run for learning?
באיזשהו הקשר? באיזה הקשרים נקרא לו? למד את זה לעומק?
נתחיל מן נתקל. באיזה הקשרים?
של קוגניציה? אוקיי, עוד קשרים נוספים ביצועים.
קוגניציה? ואתה? מהספרות הפופולרית. אבל צריך לשמוע על זה פה בקורס פה ושם.
אבל לא למדתי את זה לעומק. כן כן, לצערי יש כיום קורס.
אגב, מנטורים ששמעתי שהוא מצוין הוא יותר תיאורטי שאורן סבג מעביר מידע עם מטרה.
כן, למדתם אותו? לא. יש כאן כאלה שלקחו את Nevermind, תחום מאוד מאוד חשוב בnlp כיום החל מלפני שלוש שנים, ארבע שנים.
כן, נהיה מאוד מאוד מרכזי בתחום ואנחנו נדבר עליו ממש על קצה המזלג, מטבע הדברים.
אבל עכשיו אני רוצה דווקא להקדיש את כמה דקות של השיעור לשלב הראשון כאן, שזה הסופר Voice Fine Tuning.
אז מה בעצם הרעיון בסופר Voice Finger? אז סיימנו עם ה pre training עכשיו, מה שבדרך כלל עושים בשלב ראשון זה בעצם משהו שהוא עדיין אימון של מודל.
כן מודל כן, טכנית זה בעצם בדיוק אותו loss function.
ההבדל הוא בדאטה. כן, הדאטה בעצם שעכשיו אני עושה זה בעצם אני מנסה להגדיר אוסף של Skills.
קוראים לזה בדרך כלל בעגה הפופולרית. דברים שהייתי רוצה שהבן בוט שלי כן.
הצ'אט בוט, הצ'אט, GPT וואטאבר. קלוד שלי ידע לעשות כן.
למשל, הייתי רוצה שהוא ידע לעשות תרגילים, מתמטיקה וידע לעשות כן,
להפעיל היגיון ולתכנת ולעשות צ'אט ולא יודע מה וכן ויידע לשמור על בטיחות, כלומר לא לפלוט תכנים ניאו נאצים וכדומה.
אוקיי, אז אני מגדיר את האוסף הזה. זה אוסף שההגדרה שלו היא במידה רבה אפיון מוסרי.
בעצם כן, אפיון של מה אני רוצה בעצם שיהיה כן שיהיה בסוף במכונה שאני משחרר.
כמובן שיש כאן גם הספק טכני, כי אני צריך להגדיר איזה דברים הם.
באיזשהו מובן פורסים את מרחב האפשרויות שאני מחפש, כי אני מקווה שכן תהיה קצת הכללה מעבר לאוסף הספציפי של הדברים שלימדתי אותו,
אבל זה כבר יש כאלה שטוענים שזה wishful thinking ובעצם אני ממשיך ועושה fine tuning רק עכשיו.
המטרה שלי היא בעצם המטרה שלי.
זה לקחת דוגמאות מתויגות עם הדברים האלו ופשוט לגביהם לעשות next וורד production.
אוקיי, אז למשל, אם מה שאני רוצה ללמד אותו זה reason ing כן, אז עכשיו יש.
אז עכשיו אני נותן לו את השאלה אם כל היוונים הם בני תמותה וסוקרטס הוא יווני, אז ניתן להסיק ש.
אוקי, ואז בן אדם תייג את זה. למה סוקרטס הוא בן תמותה?
אוקיי, ואז מה שהוא צריך לחזות זה פשוט המילה הבאה.
מי אתה טה טה טה טה נובע ש סוקרטס. המילה אחריה הוא מילה אחריה.
זאת אומרת זה פשוט next post production בדיוק כמו שהיה בפרי טריינינג.
רק שעכשיו זה דוגמאות שבעצם הן דוגמאות שהן מותאמות למשימה מסוימת שאני רוצה לאמן את המודל.
אז במובן הזה זה בעצם סופר Fine Tuning, אבל בעצם אני לא משנה את ה classification head כמו שהיה לנו ב bird,
כי זה עדיין פשוט לחזות שפה זה עדיין לחזות טוקנים של השפה.
פשוט עכשיו זה שפה ספציפית לאיזשהו Task באוסף הטסטים שהגדרתי כאוסף היסודי של יכולות שאני רוצה לתמוך בהן.
זהו, אני חושב שכן. אז זה באמת זה החלק הקל של הסיפור?
הרי for learning כבר נדבר בפעם הבאה.
אז בפעם הבאה אנחנו בעצם נדבר עוד על משחק מודל ספציפית על החלק של שני.
פוסט מאת Learning. בפוסט טריינינג ואז נדבר קצת על טלקינזיס ועל אפליקציות.
ואם באמת נעלה את המבחנים ואם יש לכם שאלות אז טוב שתשלחו אליי מראש או נושאים לדיון.
זהו, אז להתראות שבוע הבא. למה? זה?
לא קורה. עכשיו.
תודה. רבה!
כן. אנחנו.
לא יודעים. מה כן?
כן, בטח ובטח. כן לא לא.
כן. לא יודעת מה. אני בטוחה. שגם קצת קשה להסביר איך זה עובד בצורה כל כך נורא.
כאילו כמה זה כבר לא כתוצאה מהשפעה אחת שעוד לא הזמנתי?
כן כן. ממש ממש לא מעמדה של סביר להסתובב שם.
הוא גם בעצמו צעק את זה בצחוק שמסביר את הבעיה או משהו בסגנון כמו שגילו את הטיפוס הזה, הוא מודה.
אבל זה לא היה הפמיניסטי. כאילו זה היה צריך לכתוב שלא לקחתי את המידע הזה.
לפוסט הבא יש יותר מדי מוסכניקים דיזל בתקופה המקבילה, שבגלל שזה המעבדה גם כן זה מה שנדרש.
שמואל ב 3 שבועות. כן אפשר ליישם זאת השאלה.
בהצלחה! אתה נראה לי כל כך קטן. מה הכוונה הכוונה שלך?
אתה גם תמצא כמה שאתה מצפה, אבל לא מה?
לא? הקישורית היא החלטתי. וואלה היית רוצה את זה ככה?
אם כבר להתאבד לנצח. נכתב על בתוכנית רגע אחרי גיל הנישואין.
טוב, זה בדיוק מה שנמצא על המצח. אני שוקל לעשות תואר שני במכון.
הגב שלי.